hey man we are
and we are back got you all already
fighting about grits in the [ __ ]
comment section
they're in the comment section fighting
about grits you look so pretty tomorrow
i thought fabio if because i you know i
feel like
you know that the mystery science
theater sketch where they had the fabio
kit
and it came with like a blonde wig that
kind of looked like that except blonde
obviously and had like a little chess
piece and then they were all like
fabio fabio that's what it reminded me
of
just that same hairstyle yeah that's a
good look for you i think
it's your wig i know
somehow i think it looks better on me
though yeah
you think i can't really drink with this
wig
[Laughter]
it does kind of hang in your face i
noticed yeah i kind of had when i wore
it i was kind of like kept
going like that i'm not used to having
like hair falling in my mouth when i'm
trying to [ __ ] do [ __ ] you know yeah
i mean
i'm immediately [ __ ] pretty though
yeah big on you're just like
god you remind me of somebody that's
driving me crazy i can't think of who it
is
that's awful some kind of 70s show you
did yeah you took a carrot top
oh yeah maybe that's what it is
you're not pale or freckly enough to be
there
carrot top got huge i know he look he
looks like
[ __ ] crazy but he got [ __ ] huge i
i don't know what he looked like the
[ __ ]
toxic avengers what he looked like i
thought
what the [ __ ] man well it wasn't just
it wasn't just the fact that he bulked
out it was also the
fact that he got really bad plastic
surgery he had his face like pulled in
all kinds of alarming directions
and it just looked really really uh like
his mouth was like this wide
you know what i'm saying like all the
way across he looked like one of those
like catfishes or something
look like a [ __ ] ginger [ __ ]
ginger uh
steven tyler on crack
[Laughter]
which that's not a good look for anybody
really
dream out
there you can make it maybe it's robert
maybe it's robert plant that i'm
thinking of
i don't know because he kind of had hair
like that at some point right
yeah kinda got it
i like they're just hanging your hair in
your face it's like tom's amazing that's
a [ __ ] man of mystery
it's [ __ ] it's painting the ass drink
with this [ __ ] we'll see how
now you understand girls pain
you know what i'm saying now we just
need to put you in a corset and some
high heels
put some long [ __ ] bails on you now
she's fantastic i look like the [ __ ] and
then you'll be like
what's the [ __ ] i'm the seventh member
of [ __ ] twisted sister
you're not gonna take it you're not
gonna yeah i ain't gonna take this
anymore
i like it yeah it's weird now because
it's weird not having a topic is it you
know what i mean you need the topic
got everybody's here [ __ ] the topics
[ __ ] topic
yeah a bunch of people did say you look
like carrot maybe that's what i was
thinking
zach said he looks like if fabio and
ronald mcdonald had a baby that you
ordered off
wish yeah nice
i think you nailed it i saw that no
sound here
at the moment can anybody hear rick had
to ask is that a wig
[Laughter]
let me see can you guys hear the music
or no
i mean we can't hear it but i have a
turn down because i don't want it i
don't want to
take that oh you stood up and i was like
i thought you were like
i thought of that because that's not
random we thought of that because i was
watching one of dan bell's
um live streams last night because
sometimes we just put it on the
background
and um they've started doing like these
kind of goofball
ghost hunts like they don't really super
believe in ghosts or anything but they
have all the ghost hunter equipment
so they go to these abandoned places and
then they just kind of dick around
and rick sarah is there and he's like
farting on the thing and it's like super
classy
and for some reason i don't know why it
makes me laugh
okay let me see
what it's like that's
oh i'm listening to my own voice but a
few
seconds behind is the music level all
right for you guys or should we drop it
down
i feel like it's too loud i think drop
it down just a little bit yeah i think
it's too loud
i think here it's just like it's hard
for us to hear because
i'm turning yeah try to try to try that
i'm turning it down to like
minus 42 decibels
that's what i thought okay
yeah that's not right okay so there we
go that's what it sounds like let me see
that's the monitor how's the sound to
you now yeah that's
it better relaxing okay uh this music
is actually i got it all from free music
archive these are like four albums by
the same
individual or band they're called
anonymous 420
you know like weed um but yeah they had
like four albums
on free music archive and i was just
like i kind of flipped through and i was
like yeah that sounds kind of cool and
vapor wavy
and i can put that in the background so
i just downloaded all four albums and
made a big [ __ ]
yeah he brought he brought props all
kinds of hats
i mean i guess i'm lucky he didn't bring
like some other props he could have
brought all kind of like
you know scary things got my [ __ ] i
don't know what she's talking
um i got i got my [ __ ] hat on there
for
that way i can change the
change the motif so um the motif
yeah so we are here at our first
long interactive
live stream it's a side track jenny was
trying to come up with a good title for
it
i was going to call it the therapeutic
apocalyptic side track
well you didn't say it all together like
well i was trying to come up with
something
like what she just posted it underwater
numbers
no i didn't i put i put what you said
first you put first apocalyptic
livestream like i don't know if that's a
good but i don't know i can change it
later whatever
it's like because i was like well i
overthink everything you know how it is
but um
but you have to overthink things you
don't get [ __ ] done right you know what
i'm saying that's that's how i justify
it
but so i'm sitting there thinking well i
don't know what we're gonna talk about
yet so
what the [ __ ] am i gonna title it so i
just had it up there like i was like
well i'll just put sidetracks live and
then the date and then i'll come up with
the title
can we title it well i know once we get
done that's what i'm saying
yeah damn damn damn damn
all right okay tila says
she likes my necklace yes it's hp
lovecraft my uh
my friend jen gave me this a very very
long time ago she got it from like from
some etsy store
they have um a bunch of different ones i
know they had a morrissey one and they
had
what was that other one i can't remember
what so they hadn't edited on the phone
but i like this one the best because it
has like tentacles
you know um yeah so
what are we uh what are we gonna talk
about
see we know we don't even know no i'm
just we're already talking now we don't
have to talk about anything
in any minute now but it's funny because
when we have a topic
yeah it's like she's worried about
topics
no i'm just no i was just saying when we
have a topic um
it's like we just keep going off on
tangents and all these other things but
we don't have a topic we're just kind of
sitting here with the thumbs up
so we can't think of anything it's not
i'm just doing what
it's not stressing me out i'm just doing
what's normal and
you're just streams going i'm not
worried about it oh i wanted to say
worrying too much about [ __ ] just
well like i said what do you want to say
you have to worry about stuff if you
want anything to get done correctly
yeah that's all i'm saying it's gonna
get done when you've got me
sitting here the shit's gonna get done
correctly it's gonna be just totally
spontaneous
totally spontaneous spontaneous
combustion spontaneous
okay so i got this in the mail the other
day
and i wasn't sure what it was because i
didn't look at it that closely and i'm
just like um
okay whatever and then finally the other
day like a couple days after i got it i
finally [ __ ] looked at it and i was
like oh duh now i get it
so it's a spoon i don't know if you can
see it because i try to put it up to the
camera
but look it says yeah this [ __ ]
look at the glare goddamn it it says
serial killer
but you know cereal like captain crunch
or some [ __ ] like that
so i'm not really sure if you sent that
but that is [ __ ] hilarious
and i'm totally gonna eat cereal with
that and probably some other things too
i could start my coffee with that i
could do all kind of fun that door
opened pookie must have knocked it open
that was closed a minute ago
wait is she in here no
she must have just opened it
you're not very interesting yeah she
does do that she does
she does kind of like go yeah and then
she just comes in and looks around and
she's like
nah nothing in here to hold my interest
she
the poor pokey you know what she did the
other night well i guess it was
yesterday right because it woke me up at
like five in the morning
she was trying to okay so we have this
um
it's like a bench thing like a long uh
black bench it's kind of velvety and
then like you can lift it up and put
[ __ ] in it but you can sit on it
and we have it it's like right flush to
the end of the bed
and pookie uses that to jump up and down
on the bed you know so she doesn't have
to jump so far
and for whatever reason i'm not sure if
she did it or if you did it
or the ghost did it i don't really know
but i guess it got pulled way out
like from the end from the end of the
bed there she is yeah she did it again
cat comes in
what are you doing we're talking about
you and she
was trying to jump i guess she was
trying to jump off of the bed and onto
the bench
and she didn't realize that the bench
had moved and there was like a big gap
there so i heard
like i heard this big crash and it woke
me up at five in the morning yeah she
failed and then i was like oh no i was
like i bet pokey fell when she was like
trying because i went and that was a big
gap
and so i was like looking for like
feeling for in the gap and everything
and i couldn't find her and then i
looked under the bed and she was under
there just looking at me and she was
just like she was embarrassed
she didn't get hurt though she it's just
her pride
[Laughter]
next week we're not going next week but
this saturday we got a show do they know
what show's coming
well everybody on uh patreon already
knows
so you can probably spoil it because i i
usually tell
what i do is when the polls uh
you know for the topics and [ __ ] clothes
on sunday at noon i usually just put it
all up so if you're on patreon
you always know like sunday like a few
minutes afternoon like what the
shows are going to be for that week like
what the movie is going to be and what
the topic is going to be for the next
week
so uh yeah so all the patrons already
know so i guess it's like fine yeah
saturday is gonna be
heaven's gate yeah yeah we're gonna
we're doing more
cult [ __ ] yeah and i said i don't want
to talk too much about heaven's gate
tonight because then we won't have any
[ __ ] to talk about on the show
but uh i was just telling him before we
came on i was like heaven's gate
i i feel better like making fun of that
because we're like making jokes on that
show because
at least those people as far as i know
um chose to do that [ __ ] it wasn't a
thing where hey we can't leave
or you know hey we're squirting poison
down our kids throats or anything like
that
um you know it was all people that are
like hey let's get on the
get let's get on the ufo and let's
castrate ourselves and
yeah that's weird
whatever man i'm not judging yeah
whatever
well it was yeah it was interesting i
was watching um if you guys don't
uh don't know about bailey what's her
name bailey sarian she does
uh murder and makeup mondays she is
super cute i love her and um
so she does all different true crime
cases and she talks about them
like kind of the way we do like in a
kind of jokey like sarcastic way but
she's like probably more
fact-based like while she does her
makeup and it's super super funny
and uh i was watching her thing on
heaven's gate today too and she was kind
of talking about when she got to the end
it was one thing that
we kind of talked about this a lot
because we talk about scientology and
all that kind of crap
but i mean at what point
at what point does do people that are in
a cult it's like can you
like go in there and get them out like
against their will you know what i'm
saying because
if you're an adult and you for real want
to like join that [ __ ]
why you turn it up everybody turn around
just a little bit
now you couldn't hear oh okay let me do
it
well let's let me do some [ __ ] it's
different i see the control
i turn it up a little bit okay yeah it
just says vaporwave right there that's
the volume thing
yeah yeah it's up a little bit there
yeah i'm checking i got the monitor
yeah i got the monitor right here
monitoring it okay i appreciate it
maybe we should close that door again
even though pookie will probably just
like pop it
it's like i don't like i don't like the
changing light type of [ __ ]
i don't like having all these factors
out of my control yeah you know what i'm
saying
it's upsetting for me but i'm just
saying how
you know like the [ __ ] that i said that
we always say about scientology i was
like well
if you're a [ __ ] grown up and you're
dumb enough to like go join that [ __ ]
like on purpose then
i don't know like i said it's it's
really got to be bad before before i
think anybody really has
kind of a right to go in there and drag
your ass out jenny sees things in a
different
in a different light than i do i can
understand how they'll take that
that a cult can find somebody who's kind
of doesn't have anything
you know i mean they don't really have
much of an identity they don't really
have a whole lot going on for them maybe
they don't have a whole lot of money
and they need a group to protect them
you know what i mean
yeah i can see that right and then the
group
typically what they do is they kind of
love bomb you yeah
where all they do is they just make you
feel like you're super welcome
and then they slowly kind of build up
this
belief system in you and then
then once they got you on that then
there's kind of like an intercult
social dynamic basically a bunch of
virtue signaling
signaling and who's going to out cult
you know someone else
who's true believer i can out cult your
oh i'll cult your ass
then they become kind of like true
believers you know
and then they're all vying for higher
positions inside the
and it can even get to the point to
where the leader of the cult says we're
all gonna [ __ ]
you know drop our bodies and go link up
with the [ __ ] ufo
you know in the tale of the [ __ ] that
always makes me think of like some
fabulous like 40s actors throwing off a
fur coat i don't know why i always have
that
so they might actually talk about that
for a long long time
oh yeah they kind of like internalize it
becomes like role-playing
but this is just all called
scientology's like that i know
and then it gets down to the point to
where they start pushing one another to
actually do [ __ ]
i'm pushing you start pushing each other
and then once they break through
boundaries once they do something then
all of a sudden freeze up they're
actually doing things
and you know scientology's been doing
things for [ __ ] decades
fair gaming people they've probably
killed people
oh it would not surprise me i'm not
gonna say that because they'll sue me
there's no proof but
um maybe they have i don't know it
wouldn't shock me if i found that out
yeah i'm just that's all i'm saying like
definitely fair game
they're definitely fair gaming people
definitely uh
locking people up in the hole you know
it wouldn't surprise me if some people
turned up missing
you know but i don't think there's any
complaints of
missing people but a lot of [ __ ] that
happens in cult stays in cult
they never go to the authorities they
don't see the authorities as a
legitimate yeah they're like oh [ __ ]
that's the american court system [ __ ]
that
you know i mean we got our own court
system it's a lot better well
scientology doesn't
yes i mean they try to handle everything
well in fact in the scientology [ __ ] it
even says
right in the thing that's one thing that
makes you an sp
is if you report anything that's going
on or you report another scientologist
whoever they are
to outside authorities that immediately
gets you branded as an sb so that's
another like reason not
you know not for people to go against
the [ __ ]
rules i'm just you know it's like i know
i know intellectually how people get
sucked into cults i've read a lot of
books about them it's like i've read
about the psychology of it i read
you know what i mean it's just i know
it's just i don't feel
that way so it's kind of like it's just
that one removed for me
so it's it's kind of hard for me to
relate to um being
so like wanting to belong to something
like that so badly
you know what i'm saying like i get it
but i don't
i don't feel like that it's real common
like i said i'm not a joiner by any
stretch of the imagination
so i don't know i can understand maybe
why other people are but i don't feel
like that so it's kind of hard for me to
like
emotionally relate to everything kind of
like that everything kind of has a
culvert
element to it kind of feel to it it
depends on how you look at it
i mean even academia is very
accomplished you know i mean just
people want to be good and if you want
to be good you want to be seen as good
then that means you're going to
make you a very good uh prospect for
a cult or some kind of a group that
includes things that aren't considered
cults
like you know organizations corporate
organizations
like in academia i don't even know if
it's
people wanting to be good as so much
wanting to belong
because some call well it depends on the
cults because like i said when we talked
about the jim jones one
i can totally see and when you talk
about scientology to a lesser extent
like before people knew like what a
[ __ ] scam it was
but prior to that i mean
jim jones church was actually doing good
[ __ ] back then it's like you know we are
helping the poor we are
you know building houses for you know
homeless people we are doing [ __ ] like
that
so i can see how you could get sucked
into something like that because
it's something that is um tangible
you know you're doing good things and
you feel good about yourself that's
fine it's just that when it gets to a
point where
[ __ ] goes off the rails you're not
allowed to question anybody anymore
you're not allowed to leave
that you can't talk to your family
anymore because they're not in it it's
you know it's a fine line that's how
that's how scientology gets people
though you know
yeah i think to help they're not helping
[ __ ] though
yeah they are all saying that you know
when they start well
i joined scientology because i wanted to
help
i wanted to make a difference in life
and i'm like i'm kind of always suspect
of people that
actually have that that attitude i want
to help
you know no i mean people should want to
help but it's like there's way
many other ways to help than joining
[ __ ] scientology
i'm like seriously just donate some
money to a food bank you're helping okay
it's like you don't have to join
anything
you don't have to do nothing like that
some of that i want to help
um attitude is in a way
kind of like uh arrogance like as if you
could help
the world's awful [ __ ] big place you
know what i mean you can help people
that you know
well that's why people within [ __ ]
within the several well that's what i'm
saying that's why it's better
to just like help people in your own
community it's like it may seem like
nothing to you
right but it's important to that person
and if everybody does that in their own
communities
like hey i'm going to donate so we can
build a library hey i'm going to give
money so you know
if everybody does that type of [ __ ] or a
lot of people do that kind of [ __ ]
then everything will get better you
don't have to like try to save the whole
entire world you're just yeah that's
what i was gonna say you know the point
is is that uh
no that's not what they want the i want
to help thing
in terms of the scientology they want to
help clear the [ __ ] planet well yeah
but they're they want to help clear the
[ __ ] planet at thirty thousand
dollars ahead
but they're not kidding all right so
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
want to help
[ __ ] out of here crazy well and then
that
the thing about it and even like [ __ ]
tom cruise has said this [ __ ] too
where they they've gotten to such a
point
that now they think they're the only
ones that can help or they're the only
ones that are equipped
to like help people out like an accident
they're the first one on the scene
[ __ ] the paramedics we got
scientologists here yeah we're going to
get
a [ __ ] touch assist yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] man it's like not gonna
look like pookie looked at me like
where's that
well you know he's he's saying this to
the cult
it's that was an occult advertisement
called propaganda
i mean that whole thing has to toe that
line right it's one big circle
it sounds like [ __ ] total lunacy to a
to a civilian non-scientologist
but to them that was exactly what they
want to hear well yeah like we're the
only effective
[ __ ] people on the planet [ __ ]
you're on the sea org you're working all
the time you're [ __ ]
you're trying to smoke as much as you
can to avoid cancer
it's all kinds of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] i
love it i love it yeah well make it
stronger
i love to be honest with you a lot of
resistance to cancer yeah
because that's how that works but um i
love
we love like leah remini's show because
i love that she
that she got out of it and i mean she
was raised in it from a kid you know
what i mean because her mom was in it
and got her involved when she was real
young she was like how old was she when
she got in 10 12 something like that she
was a kid
and then she managed to get out and you
know she has the balls to just like
actually go after them and call them out
on their [ __ ] which i think is
awesome
but she's also on her show she's real
open about
how she felt and how she got sucked into
the [ __ ] and she does really say
she's like you go to those big [ __ ]
if you've seen them on youtube because
somebody like leaked them or whatever
if you go to like their big you know
jerk off whatever odd
like fake oscars or whatever the [ __ ] it
is that they do
where they give people like medals and
all that whatnot and uh and everybody
has to go to it or there's like a lot of
pressure on you to go to it
and she's like all they do that whole
time is just talk about how many new
orgs they build how many new people they
recruited
and she's like and it's all [ __ ]
because they'll be like oh we
you know we got this many new um i don't
even know if they call it recruits they
use some little [ __ ] weaselly kind
of words where
there's basically like well we handed
out
flyers to this many people you know not
saying that 99.99
have just like chucked him in the
[ __ ] garbage like two seconds after
that
they're they're just saying that so
they're like claiming all of the people
that they handed a flyer to
in the streets of every country around
the world as
a as outreach they're count they're i
can't remember the phrase that they used
but i thought it was very funny because
it was obvious that they were
they didn't want to say that they
recruited those people because those
people were just like okay whatever yeah
oh they're asking tila was asking if
scientology did outreach
like community outreach yeah they do and
boy called who was that
but they're not they're not really very
helpful his name is trevor
what they do is they have kind of oh
[ __ ] what do they call the [ __ ]
he mentioned they got what volunteer
ministries yeah yeah yeah they got those
yellow shirts
that says that [ __ ] on the back when if
there's ever a [ __ ]
uh a disaster they send out volunteer
ministries
all right which is the [ __ ] wackiest
[ __ ] you've ever seen it's a bunch of
sea org members
they're they they call them volunteer
ministers
in this circumstance normally they're
just slaves
unloading boxes [ __ ] sweeping floors
staffing orgs building [ __ ] they don't
[ __ ] pay him
all right normally that's what they're
doing if something like a katrina
happens they'll round up a bunch of them
because you guys are now all volunteer
ministers put these t-shirts on
it says volunteer ministers go touch
some people you've spoiled it
no comedic timing so they sent them to
the [ __ ] you sent them to the [ __ ]
disaster zone all right they get there
they set up tents they have all this
[ __ ] emergency relief looking
equipment
they're in [ __ ] orange [ __ ] vests
or just whatever they look like they're
[ __ ] paramedics right and what do
they do they take [ __ ]
disaster victims and they put them on
these cots and give them something
called touch assist which is not even a
massage
it's just they just touch them in
special places so the [ __ ]
uh what do you call it they're ot powers
they're operating themes they can use
spiritual energy of some sort space
spirits
to [ __ ] uh make them feel better and
then they give them a brochure about
scientology and try to get them to join
and they get [ __ ] credit with the irs
somehow by saying that they did
disaster relief yeah and basically all
they did they're like that's all it is
okay so you just lost your home and your
entire family give you katrina
does this make you feel better here this
will take it out and then go me
yeah the volunteer the volunteer
ministers are
touching you getting your yeah i don't
want any scientologists touching me in
special places
you know what i'm saying you're trying
to get those get those engrams out of
you those [ __ ] things were the
engrams
god damn i can't even remember remember
that what it was in engram
the evil alien souls that are attached
to your soul are they called engrams
i thought they were yeah i think they
are right i get i get the mythology
confused sometimes because it doesn't
make any [ __ ] yeah
actually i think you have to [ __ ]
become a clear and then go up through
like ot one two three and four to get
rid of engrams
so but they can so touch assist doesn't
get rid of them
it's probably just like it it relieves
stress or pain
all right and then they get up and then
they give them a [ __ ] brochure
and then they take all the statistics
from that how many touch assists they
did
how many brochures they handed out how
fast it was to [ __ ] set up all the
cops all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
they send all that [ __ ] back to the
church of scientology where it's
recorded
meticulously recorded and [ __ ] filed
away on paper probably
and filing cabinets that way it takes up
as much space as possible
besides they do exactly what lrh told
them to do back in the 60s
and the 50s nothing's changed they still
use
telex machines yeah because lrh told
them to send out
telex's every morning yeah for the
report so it's got to be telex
it can't be email can't be a message on
[ __ ]
messenger or facebook it's gotta be a
telex
[ __ ] ridiculous which like people
don't even know what the [ __ ] that is
anymore yeah
where do they even get that i'm sure
like the people that make the [ __ ]
telex machines that's their only client
telex was even telex was even pre
that was that was pre-fax machine
pre-fax machine it's like a fax machine
but it's like
it's like a proto fax machine
almost it's not like a mimeograph is it
yeah remember no no no it came out
through a telephone
yeah that's right so it is so it is like
effects
yeah you took the phone receiver and you
put it on a machine
and then a signal would come through and
it would [ __ ] print it out
yeah type it out yeah filthy gardener
said complimentary hand job for
surviving an earthquake
right that's like that's what i'm
thinking of yeah and i'm like look it's
like i just survived a disaster i don't
want some [ __ ] weird stranger
touching me
read what tila said about the scab
so when i pulled that scab off the leg
of the jehovah's witness when i was a
year old i was actually doing the touch
assist with them
well everybody knows exactly what it is
it's a it's something that they can
offer for free
and they can go to a place where there's
a disaster and they can hand out
brochures
and make it look like they did something
to the irs and it didn't cost them
yeah it's just it's low effort low low
cost
yeah it's just kind of like it you know
what i mean it's like not to be an
[ __ ] but it's just like offering
thoughts and prayers to people it's like
literally that's the least you could do
you know what i mean it doesn't take it
doesn't cost you anything
no time no nothing it's just kind of
like but it makes you feel better like
you actually [ __ ] did something
even though you didn't do anything so i
kind of feel like
i mean at least they go there but they
only go there to promote scientology
that's they don't give a [ __ ] about the
people that survived katrina they don't
give a [ __ ] about that they just want to
like
pass the brochures out and get more
people yeah
but they're doing that actually they
pass those brochures out and they don't
get
more people but they well no everybody
just probably goes
yeah the reason why they pass the
brochures out is that helps with their
tax exempt
status because it makes them look like a
religion yeah because they're doing all
those
[ __ ] everything that they do pretty much
i'd say probably 90 of everything the
church of scientology does
they do it to keep that tax exempt
status yeah they keep buying [ __ ]
buildings because they can't they have
to
yeah because they can't hoard money they
have to spend it back into the church
because it's supposed to be kind of like
a church or a charity
so they can't just let their damn bank
account expand they've got as much as
they might want to they just got to keep
buying buildings and buildings and
buildings
and uh the more buildings they have the
same thing catholic church does probably
the more uh the more buildings they have
the more space they take up the more
they can say they're a religion
well and they really miscavidge really
hits that hard too with their little
fake oscar ceremonies or whatever
and he sounds just like a [ __ ] he
sounds like a game show host or some
[ __ ] like every time it's [ __ ]
hilarious if you want to go
and then we did this little thing and da
da da da
5 000 [ __ ] things cute enough yeah
it's like it's that kind of [ __ ]
70 000 touch assists and i'm like if you
are not like people that are not in
scientology you listen to it and it
sounds
it sounds like a joke yeah it sounds
like a parody it doesn't sound like
anything that anyone
that not even a child would believe that
this year thirty thousand people reached
clear
we have [ __ ] nine million new members
they're like nine million new members
this year that's [ __ ] still like
drinking drinking no i don't think so
yeah it sounds like some cheesy [ __ ]
game show from like the
[ __ ] 70s or something actually you
know what it sounds like a sales
convention
sales like i said it's like a crazy game
show from the 70s
like from magazine from magazine sales
or vacuum cleaner sales
how how much the company expanded it's
very very corporate
um this actually gets back to some of
the [ __ ]
that i've said during the shows
world war ii really [ __ ] america up
and part of it was the merger
of [ __ ] state powers and corporate
powers the military trying to be like a
corporation
well ron hubbard was in involved in
in the military becoming a corporation
he was in world war ii
so he decided that you know what
religions have to become corporations
and [ __ ] scientology is very
it's a religion but it's more of a
corporation
oh yeah big time kind of like amway
i think that's a very close equivalent
very much like amway
and uh it's
it just shows how corporate culture and
corporate thinking
in the end destroys everything their
corporations
and the [ __ ] that they say and do
and the [ __ ] that they spend money
on
it's it's it's gonna it's destroying the
earth
uh it will eventually people in the 20s
and 30s were
terrified of corporations um
mussolini uh fascism okay was base
was a part of socialism started off as a
as socialism but the italian version of
it that mussolini and all of
all his boys were involved in was i
forgot the name
of their particular kind of fascism
it's fascism but it's the fascism where
everyone is in some kind of a union
and the unions all kind of i guess you
could say
kind of like throne sniff the [ __ ]
head of a government like an emperor
and that emperor passes things out to
these
unions and it be and the state
has become basically a union and a
corporation
at the same time and they called it
fascism
the the merger of state incorporation
into into a single thing
and that's what the chinese model is
it's very much
what the german national socialist was
like the
the nazis they were kind of like that
they had a slightly different
interpretation
the soviet union had was a lot like that
but a little bit of a different
interpretation it was an
international version of that man
i hate to tell you you know what i mean
a lot of the united states is starting
to look
like mussolini's fascism in a certain
way
corporations have just kind of merged
with the state and the military
and it's very dangerous because what you
end up with eventually is just
feudalism basically because it doesn't
protect human rights
but scientology is
what happens when the corporate
mentality meets the religious world it
becomes a very abusive
just and it's just it's so weird it's
and like i said
i've read more l ron hubbard than i ever
thought that i would in my entire life
just because of that stuff
[ __ ] [ __ ] that i worked at agent
media corporation
that's what it was i don't know it's
probably not there anymore so it was in
clearwater
and like i said i think i mentioned this
before but the first half hour of every
workday
you spent in the classroom on the first
floor
yeah reading l ron hubbard's [ __ ] about
business
they couldn't put all his like
scientology [ __ ] in there
but they could say well we think that he
um
you know knew everything there was to
know about running a business so we can
talk about his business ideas so you
could so
you know i did the communication course
i did all his like businessy [ __ ]
so we did all of that and even reading
that
i don't know man it was just it's hard
it was a long time ago so it's like hard
for me to remember but i just remember
reading it and being like
one this dude's a lunatic and two
he's not a very good writer either but
also it's like he
seemed to really think or at least he
was trying to make other people believe
that growth could be
infinite yeah no it can't yeah i'm like
you do know there are like
limitations to [ __ ] right it's like he
really didn't seem to get that
he's getting that from he's getting that
from corporations yeah that's what i'm
saying
it was very corporating very corporate
where sales figures have to be
at least higher than they were last week
they
must be if not then heads will roll when
people will be fired yeah they only want
people that can
increase sales figures every [ __ ]
year
so if you sold 10 last week you got to
sell 11
this week and then 12 next week
and if that doesn't happen you're fired
well yeah that's exactly what they were
doing yeah and you had to
every single like i said and i don't
know if i've mentioned this before but
every single job it was called a hat for
[ __ ] sake
because you you know you wear the hat of
your job i gotta check the mail real
quick
oh yeah okay i'm waiting on that power
cube oh that's right he's got a package
he's got a package coming so he we've
got we have so many charging cables and
they all seem to be like breaking but
they're cheap ones
but yeah so everyone's hat you had your
own [ __ ]
um like a little binder or whatever that
said what your
duties were i said duty and um
so and and it said like what your
it pretty much assigned every single
task a point value essentially
so every you every single week you
couldn't just do your [ __ ] job and go
home
you had to do your [ __ ] job and then
you had to say oh okay today
i did this many corrections i did this
many this that and the other
and then you had to add up all your
points so we learned very quickly that
every week i think it was monday morning
like you'd have the big meeting
and they would take all of your stats
from friday and they would have a graph
printed out of if you were up stat or
down stat
and if you were up stat you know they
would say hey here's jenny's thing
and she's upstat this week everyone
would clap
and if you were down stat everyone would
not clap and they would just like look
at you yeah it's just like
just like a second right so everybody
very quickly that wasn't a scientologist
learn to just like make
up make up your stats your stats because
why wouldn't you
they just they're not going to check
[ __ ] off
well they do that exact same thing in
north korea maoist china the old soviet
union every day there was self-criticism
and then and you also have to fill out
forms every [ __ ] day you work to do
that to constantly
keep production high yeah it's like i
already gotta work here why i gotta do
all this stupid extra [ __ ] it's
so pointless when the state becomes a
corporation that's what you have to deal
with
but uh hey look today you know at the
part of the element of this show is it's
interactive
so it's kind of like an open open lines
show
so if you have any questions for us or
you have any ideas
you know like you want to know about
ghosts or you want to know about any
kind of certain case
we'll answer anything chances are me and
jay know about within reason
within reason if not we'll just go to
another one although i can't really
think of anything that i wouldn't answer
although i'm sure someone will probably
come up with something
well that too i'm just no i'm just
saying like if somebody wanted to ask
questions like about me personally or
you personally
it's like i could tell [ __ ] the [ __ ]
off well no i'm just saying i don't
really have any shame so i don't really
know if like anybody
could ask me anything that would offend
me or anything like that that's what i'm
saying
that that um those those charging cables
it says they're out for delivery
well oh is it fedex
no it's amazon oh
yeah sometimes well they come late
sometimes yeah i usually get
i mean if amazon brings [ __ ] to the door
i usually just get a little pop-up on my
computer
isn't this a great time to be alive i
get a little pop-up and they send me a
picture they're like
look the shit's on your doorstep there
it is somebody asked me tom have you
played outer worlds it's like fallout
but in space no i've never heard of it
sounds
loud in space
actually i've been playing uh metal gear
solid five that's what i've been playing
right now
and that and the new uh star wars uh
is it is it like an x-wing i forgot what
it was called
star wars it's it's the flying game as
you just fly around
the flying game i like to fly
some people don't like flying games i
like i like flying games of fighter
pilot
mango has a question tom do you use a
food processor
when you're cooking uh no we have a
ninja
yeah that's just for making smoothies
and [ __ ] but um
well the only thing that we usually make
it sometimes sometimes if we're making
indian food like something if you we can
we uh smush up like onions and nuts and
stuff like that to make a base like for
curries and [ __ ]
yeah but other than that we don't really
use it that way yeah no i make iced
coffee in it every now and then
like squish up the ice like a
frappuccino yeah if you're trained
cooked and you just use a kitchen
knife you you have good knife skills so
you can
dice chop julienne you can do all that
just by hand you don't really need
you know i don't need a food processor
but if i'm gonna do something like
puree a bunch of sauteed
onions into a paste that for used for a
thickening agent
for indian food you're just going to use
like a food processor i like that i'll
use a ninja for that
it'll turn it into like a like the
consistent apple sauce yeah those onions
someone asked if you could fist fight
any animal what animal would you fight
if i could fist fight any animal
whatever any animal
uh like try am i trying to get a good
fight like a good even
a cockroach
[Laughter]
and have a good fight where either one
of you could win it'd be a [ __ ]
kangaroo
well yeah that seems the other day yeah
they'll stand up and then maybe bear
a second one or a chimpanzee nah champa
[ __ ] you they could kick your ass
only if you'd have to muzzle the chimp
so it couldn't bite you they'll but they
could bite a hand off right at the wrist
or you're screwed a lot of bite pressure
so it's not a fair fight
cause don't the chimps i mean they
pretty a mailchimp will go right for
your [ __ ] scrotum it'll do anything
bite your face off just whatever it can
get yeah like that one
but in terms of like a fair fight a
kangaroo
i feel like a kangaroo would fight well
like i said if i could fist fight any
animal i'm gonna i'm gonna fist fight
one that i could like whip their ass
obviously
and animal and an animal that i don't
like so i pick a cockroach well
yeah that's not a fair fight though you
outmatched well that wasn't the question
yeah i think i thought he was asking
what would be the
the most fair fight would probably be a
[ __ ] room
kangaroo plus i wouldn't want to hurt a
kangaroo because they're super cute
no okay i've seen [ __ ] videos of
kangaroos running up on guys and just
started [ __ ] whipping ass on a dude
well they're still for no reason
no they they don't care they don't like
people no they don't like people
the males evidently kind of go into rut
and
if they see anything they don't like
they attack it because there's females
males of every species they're a menace
yeah that's the way it is
you know what's weird i was thinking
about that lady that the the chimp
better face off the other
day i don't know i don't remember why i
was thinking about it
somebody wanted to see me to recreate a
famous six million dollar man battle
where a six million dollar man fights a
bigfoot
remember bionic bigfoot yeah
yeah [ __ ] six million dollars man
ripped off [ __ ] buying a bigfoot's
arm
you took it back to oscar oscar look
what i found
you know because oh that's a biotic
bigfoot yeah
like some of you guys we didn't make
this so many people
some of you kids are not old enough to
remember the [ __ ] six million dollar
man
i used to love that [ __ ] program when
i was a kid we used to [ __ ]
we it's like i was in the third third
grade i think we used to [ __ ] make
the six million dollar man's sound
effect while we were doing you know well
yeah
i still do that now and then when we
would run we would run in slow motion
and go now yeah
yeah me and my brother
slow motion you were going fast yeah
yeah yeah i'm going so fast that people
can't even like
receive it yes you guys so you gotta
slow it down yeah
that was on me that was that was a
mystery science theater skit too where
they where
uh mike i think it was i think it was a
mic episode but mike gave the bots
a six million dollar man sounds so every
time they moved they were like
and they were delighted and started
jumping around and then he got annoyed
and had a turn
somebody said that they're gonna send us
a package with some cds and a bunch of
other stuff oh boy
i love packages yeah songs doesn't have
anything that'll like blow up or dead
rats or anything in it
nobody ever sent us anything back
everybody sent us good [ __ ]
i know yeah but you know there's always
one oh
man so somebody asked if we had watched
i guess that was it netflix you guys i
guess netflix just added a new
documentary about
the night the original night stalker or
the night stalker night stalker
that's what because you guys are saying
night stalker but i don't know there's
two nightstalkers that's what i mean
there's night stalker and there's
original nightstalker it was
that d'angelo [ __ ] yeah d'angelo was
the original
but nobody knew that until recently well
yeah because they didn't catch until
much later
i called it man i figured that [ __ ] out
i can't believe they finally caught that
yeah i figured that [ __ ] out i'm so
happy i was so happy well i mean you
know it took him forever but
you know what are you gonna do i thought
it's weird because
i could imagine what he was doing
you know what i mean yeah everybody have
to be a cop or a soldier
but i was thinking a cop yeah
i think he was a little bit uh wasn't he
a marine before he was a guy i think he
wasn't
he was in the marines wasn't he i think
he was yeah i can't remember
but yeah he was all up in that [ __ ] but
yeah he was a cop
and uh yeah as i said cops are kind of
like um
overrepresented in syria well there's a
lot of cops
well i know that i'm i'm not saying that
of that ergo
all cops are serial killers that's a
that's obviously a stupid statement
i'm just saying yeah but i can't
i can't um you have to compensate for
stupidity out there
i can't do that because like some people
are just so stupid that i can't thank
you mango oh my god
great to have the side tracks back even
better live flash hey thanks [ __ ]
badger what's up bro
thank you thank you showing us some
flash balls this is actually pretty fun
because
i don't it's a little more of a
free-flowing show because it's weird
like every time we kind of stop talking
i'm like oh i should go back to my notes
and then i'm like
oh yeah i don't have any notes but yeah
so
what was i saying oh yeah it just seems
like
you can't even make a statement like oh
cops are overrepresented in serial
killers because some idiot somewhere
well you're saying old cup to steer like
i'm like that's obviously not what i
said i'm just saying
that among serial killers which is
already a vanishingly small percentage
of the population
that uh you know if cops is not number
one i don't think i think
truck driver truck drivers is number one
or it's in the top five i remember um
it was it was [ __ ] like it was cops
truck drivers
um what the [ __ ] unemployed no no um
mechanics um
working that's just working class people
like forest rangers
yeah i think that was in the top five
also it was jobs like that
it wasn't anything like you know it
wasn't doctors or lawyers or nothing
like that
but it could be it could just be that
serial killers that are doctors and
lawyers are too smart to get caught
too uh yeah maybe some of them are kind
of like
angels of mercy type that's what i was
thinking of because we didn't show the
same
i don't think it's the same kind of guy
it's well yeah it's a different uh
it's a different uh pathology that is
the problem with um
you gotta say this you gotta eat serial
killers and criminals are attracted to
power
they want to go where power is um
they'd probably like to be in in
politics that's where the real power is
power and money but most of them
don't have the background that it takes
to make it in politics
so they end up trying to go to places
kind of like the military
or but you know the military probably
wouldn't be very satisfying
because a lot of serial killers had a
military background but they didn't do
anything while they were in the military
yeah they were there a few years and
then yeah it's because you're not free
in the military you're just not
all right so the next choice would be
will this be a cop when a cop you have a
when you're a cop you have a lot more
freedom you know what i mean a lot less
supervision
so you can really [ __ ] up as a cop all
right
yeah and being a cop this is i'm not
saying this against the cops have worked
with cops there's a lot of good cops
that i know
unfortunately
i haven't i haven't [ __ ] spoken to
any cops in a long time but
man today the environment right now is
not a pro
cop environment so good guys
will not be wanting to join the police
force right now
which that's bad because the only guys
that would want to join it right now are
[ __ ] either losers
or bad dudes
law enforcement is a [ __ ] not an old
profession really it's
well as we know it now all the [ __ ]
police forces that you have right now
have have a corporate nature to them
just like everything else
it's not originally the way cops were
originally they were just
like out out in the old west you know he
had a sheriff he hired guys
they were kind of like a posse more
anything else and they could have been
train robbers before they were cops they
didn't
you know men of action are men of action
yeah they're just like whatever they
don't
came to the new town yeah yeah okay just
shoot the people we want you to
yeah right people try to moralize this
[ __ ] too much and the world doesn't
really work that way
so the same kind of guy who was robbing
a bat who was robbing a train a couple
states over says you know i don't want
to rob trains anymore
i want to be i want to [ __ ] be a
sheriff i want to be a law man i'm going
to try my hand at that
and here's the weird thing that didn't
necessarily mean that the guy would be a
bad
cop probably a real good cop people are
complicated
because because now he thinks he knows
exactly how
an outlaw is going to think because he
was one
but in common but you know in pop
culture
on the theater who else was like that
who else was like that
i don't know
axel foley he said well i wasn't always
a cop he had hoodlum friends and [ __ ]
sometimes those kind of guys make a
pretty good cops
you don't want a boy scout up there all
the time because that motherfucker's
soft
all right so
i'm not sure exactly where i was going
with all this because i'm [ __ ]
drinking but uh
wait where [ __ ] going with that
because of the way uh
way shit's going now [ __ ] um i think
everything's gonna
become a lot more local all right and uh
and less corporate and uh
one of the things that's really gonna
suffer is [ __ ] the law law
enforcement as a as a business
i think the future of law enforcement's
to look a lot like the past of law
enforcement it's going to go back to
what it looked like in the 20s probably
it's not good because a cop in the 20s
in the united states is more like a mall
cop
they didn't do anything they don't do
nothing
all right um civilization's a fragile
system
and that's the way it was in brazil when
i was there
there were about three different kinds
of cops
a city cop which was like a [ __ ] mall
cop
a state cop which was just a like like a
mall cop with a little bit better
weaponry
then there was the military police which
was the army
and because brazil at that time had just
come out of a military dictatorship
the only reliable police force they had
was the army
and it was still unreliable uh
[ __ ] who actually ran the show where
ex-military militias and drug cartels
they actually ran the streets not the
cops
and um is that a bad situation
yeah it's a bad situation was it fun
[ __ ] yes it was fun
[ __ ] yes it was fun i love brazil it was
in the time that i was there it was
anarchy
you could do whatever you wanted but you
had to be careful because
you could do whatever you wanted it was
like the old west
if he gets up we all get up it'll be
anarchy it'll be anarchy
yeah anarchy actually that was a
breakfast club i guess
in the 80s when i was there the
brazilian government was only for the
rich people
it was only for the rich people and the
government it was
the the purpose of the government was to
protect the government
and the rich people that supported the
government everybody else
ah [ __ ] them that was the thinking
they weren't they weren't team players
they didn't have anything they weren't
useful
so they were just on their own and why
because it was a collapsed system
it was anarchy you know and
and why because it was illegitimate
basically it was fake
when people don't believe in the
legitimacy of a government it just kind
of falls apart
um it doesn't really go mad max
like a lot of people think it does it
continues to function people still work
it's just that there's no real law and
order
and nobody really cares
the only thing i didn't like about
brazil is that the ruling class
controlled everything
and they didn't want importation they
wanted everyone to be a captive audience
buying their products
so you couldn't buy anything from
overseas even to this day it's hard to
buy something overseas in brazil well
yeah because they want to force you to
buy their lane
all the money they wanted all the money
well yeah if you have a monopoly then
like it doesn't matter what kind of crap
you
[ __ ] out yeah so everybody can just [ __ ]
out some shitty shitty [ __ ]
and [ __ ] make everybody buy that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and you're like a good product from
[ __ ] japan or [ __ ]
it's just shitty you know but
no drinking age that place was just sexy
as [ __ ]
this was everyone with their big booties
just big booties and [ __ ] just
everybody having a good time i think
that's all tom cared about really
he could just drink and follow he's
around yeah
well one of the things is that when a
country declines into [ __ ] anarchy
and poverty
the ruling class realizes that the only
way they can maintain
control is to make everybody happy so
they just allow booze and drugs and just
everything to just flow
yeah they don't everybody just shut up
just stay high have a party and [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] leave us alone and you
know it kind of divides into two
worlds an upper world and a lower world
kind of like that star trek what was
that star trek episode where they had
people living in the clouds and other
people [ __ ] down in the damn yeah
it's like that like that well it's kind
of like the time machine too with the
eloy
yeah right you know okay so
people are asking favorite non-horror
movie
mulholland drive david lynch
favorite non-horror movie and also
they're asking favorite comedy
which is hard ghostbusters or young
frankenstein
for me wow i don't have to think about
that
favorite non-horror movie and favorite
comedy
or maybe clue god damn it okay
i'm not a big fan of comedies in general
but i like a lot of uh
probably ghostbusters i i always divide
all these favorite movies up
into time periods well it's really i
mean old or new ones
if i had to like make a list of like my
favorite movies i would have to do it by
like
genre right because it's like i was like
i can't say that say ghostbusters is a
better movie
than like [ __ ] um the exorcist
they're two completely different kind of
movies
and like there's a lot you're saying
comedy but i like comedies where you can
learn a lot of [ __ ] there's a lot like
idiocracy
is a comedy i [ __ ] love idiocracy but
it's also very
educational it's very educational
because
there's a lot of truth in it i like
money i like money you like money yeah i
like money
isn't mulholland drive a horror movie
though i don't know if i'd call it a
horror movie david lynch had
he occupies a weird liminal space
between
i don't know i don't know what genre i
would call that
i would call that maybe a mystery or a
thriller maybe more than a horror movie
although it has a couple of horror movie
elements
i don't think i would call it then
there's another comedy that i
it's newer that i would i i would
consider it my favorite but i don't even
know if it's a comedy
because it had funny parts to it but
it's also kind of dark and there's a lot
of truth to it and that was art of
self-defense
but that was definitely a comedy it's
coming i mean i thought it was hilarious
it's a comedy but it's also kind of like
a moral it also had some moral lessons
and it was
kind of a [ __ ] up thing it kind of
[ __ ]
all right it was kind of an
examination of [ __ ] what people would
call toxic
masculinity yeah that's what i thought
was so funny
but it's the thing is though is you have
to understand and understand who wrote
this movie
okay the dude who wrote this movie is
kind of like the protagonist in the
movie this guy is just [ __ ] soy as
[ __ ] all right he's not wrong in his
observations
obviously
[Laughter]
he's not wrong in his observations but
it's funny about
what he's talking about that there is a
certain amount of reality to it
but his reaction to it is also funny to
me the whole [ __ ] thing is kind
of like
it's kind of meta it is yeah but i do
like it
i do like it he is telling the truth and
to a certain extent
everything it's not what yoda says many
of the things that we cling to
all right maybe the truths that we cling
to often depend upon a certain point of
view
so i can take two opposing point of
views at once
and appreciate them both and then still
[ __ ]
select one or the other you know i mean
i'm not real wrapped up
in i don't want to say like i'm a
sociopath but i don't care about right
and wrong it's just
you kind of are though maybe i kind of
am
wrapped up in in in right and wrong i
really don't care about what society's
view of right and wrong is because
you look at the average person in
society i just don't that you know just
the average person is just you know blah
so i'm not really i don't really care
you know it sometimes because i know the
reality is is that sometimes you might
have to do something that's wrong
but then it serves a greater good but
the greater good is an opinion and it's
always an opinion
everything is like a kind of a gray you
know that's just that's just the way it
is
well yeah you know i figured that out a
lot it's just the way it is
but my fa you know what my favorite
scene in art of self defense
is when because he's portrayed i mean
it's
it's an exaggeration obviously that he's
really really
like he doesn't like to leave his house
and he's super awkward and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
but then he goes when he starts going to
the um
to sensei and learning all those lessons
and stuff he goes like 180 degrees in
the other direction
so then he's just like in the [ __ ]
break room
of work and then that dude just like
starts [ __ ] when he just like punches
him in the face
it's like that just [ __ ] cracks me up
so the thing is though is that
the [ __ ] that's getting the
instructions name is casey
okay his name is casey and he's just soy
ass
[ __ ] and his instructor
sensei okay is this other dude who's
doing [ __ ]
basically criminal [ __ ] okay it is
criminals
it's criminal [ __ ] all right he has
gotten kind of strong but what
it turns out later on when you're
watching the movie turns out that sensei
his name is leslie yeah okay
and he was just as soy as casey when
casey started
so of course his toxic masculinity it's
that overcompensation it's oh he's
there it's a weak man over compensation
that's what i find funny right and that
is the part of the truth
of of that because that's i've seen that
before yeah because the more
you have to go out of your way to go
look how
manly manly and tough i am then that
then everybody
you well and every woman in the world
is immediately like oh okay yes
[ __ ]
so but i thought the movie was accurate
because
it wasn't an attack on masculinity it
was an attack on toxic masculinity show
you exactly what toxic masculinity was
a man trying to be more than a man but
he didn't really have the background he
didn't know what being a man was
and he was doing [ __ ] that was just just
being a dick
he was just being a dick that's not
being a man no that's being
that's just being a douche well that's
what i'm saying you're just picking on
innocent people for no reason
no to get it out of your system right
which that's you know obviously yeah
well that's it's toxic masculinity
yeah like i said that's why i like that
movie so much
because they really [ __ ] nailed that
[ __ ] yes it's exaggerated but not that
much
yeah i didn't find it that exaggerated
yeah it wasn't that exaggerated there
were no i didn't existed
that's what i mean i don't think that
was that exaggerated count dante was
dante and the black dragon fighting for
society we're like that
pretty much kinda yeah yeah so that
so knowing the history of martial arts
and martial artists
i was like yeah that's it now
the movie does come back and say that
what you've seen here is not true
martial arts
it's a twisted version of march martial
arts
but you have to understand if you really
examine martial arts dojos there were
many twisted examples of martial arts
dojos
because the guys running them were
[ __ ] charlatans yeah
they were charlatans yeah going back
trying to throw she bought chee balls
and [ __ ]
oh my god dylan i love this balls
[ __ ] well you know if you have one
toe up it won't tell down it'll
counteract the chee ball
if you have your tongue on this well
don't tell everybody that yeah yeah
because now you try to do that [ __ ] on
me i'm just gonna go
yeah i win crazy [ __ ] stupid ass come on
now
it's just it it amazes me like the [ __ ]
people got away with but
well i guess people still get away with
telling stupid lies nowadays but
back then you couldn't like check why
zach brought up
uh hereditary yeah man
i loved that movie so much you guys
that's it that's probably
if i had to pick my favorite movie the
last five ten years it's probably that
but like i said it's it's one of those
movies because my whole
i love horror movies i still watch them
even though
you know they don't really give me
nightmares anymore or anything like that
but that movie did
and that was the first time that that
had happened
and even though i was mad at it for
doing that for [ __ ] me up for
a couple weeks afterwards i was happy
because i was kind of like man
it's been since i was a kid when i first
saw the shining
yeah that made me not want to go to the
bathroom in the middle of the night
that was the first time that that had
happened like in my adult life
all right tina's asking me what the
favorite action movie is
and uh this is another thing
what is an action movie i mean there are
some things
she's so nebulous yeah they're like what
is an action movie they're
they're a lot a real [ __ ] action
movie
all right would have been some [ __ ] like
blood sport you could say that's an
action movie
just a ridiculous story of [ __ ] frank
dix and him [ __ ]
is that a great movie no not really i
mean
it's hilarious when you know the story
behind it
i mean when you say what's my favorite
what the favorite action movie would be
there's two of them that immediately
come to mind but then i want then i
asked myself well is that an
action movie predator predator is that
an action movie
it's action horror yeah because it's
kind of like a monster movie it's kind
of like a horror
military sci-fi military horror
kind of movie all right i don't know
it's it doesn't have
a lot of the stuff that a major action
movie had
which is car chases and buses flipping
and [ __ ]
the best action movie probably just in
terms of action would be terminator 2
but i don't like that movie i just don't
like terminator 2 sorry people
terminator 1 was a lot better and that's
more like a horror movie
i liked terminator 2 when i saw it the
first time but when i watched it again
recently i still liked it but i don't
like it
it's not that good i mean and it's
mostly because of that kid that kid
ken ruins at the top the tone ruins it
it's very
corporate it's so nice 90s it's just not
that good
and i really didn't age well i think
that was one thing when i say that i
mean because i'm not
saying that there wasn't good [ __ ] that
came out in the 90s because obviously
there was there's a lot of good movies
came out in the 90s
but i think that there was a lot of [ __ ]
that came out in the 90s the whole
that whole like kid or teenager being
like
a wise talking smart ass
there was a lot of that in the 90s and i
hated that
yeah it was like a [ __ ] and that and
terminator 2
had that in space yeah it's like a 90s
you know what i mean it just had edward
furlong it's like look i'm just i'm like
12 and i'm such a badass
yeah i'm smoking and i'm like making all
these like and then
slangy kind of it's like and that just i
don't know it gets on my nerves and
and it didn't date very well yeah and
then you know is
is is aliens or alien 2 is that an
action movie
i guess alien one i would call that a
horrible
horror movie right sci-fi horror i guess
even though it's more like a horror
movie i think it's more a horror movie
it's a monster movie it's just aliens i
would have to say that
if predator is an action movie then
that's my favorite action movie
that would probably be mine as well well
i don't know there's a lot after that
would be
alien too they're aliens maybe aliens
would be for i don't know
oh that's hard now there's something
about predator that's just
the edit i never get sick i mean i never
get sick of predator and i never get
sick of aliens
right either i could just watch them
over and over
and i i think that's kind of that's
something that really goes a long way
toward what my favorite movies are still
if i can watch it over and over and not
get sick of it
and or always find something different
in it that's that's why like i never get
sick of the shining
if you said right now hey let's watch
the shining okay
yeah i've see i've probably seen it a
hundred times
and i never get tired of it yeah just
never
yeah tina's going on about t1 and t2 t1
is a
superior movie to t2 even though t2 had
a bigger budget
and it was just there was a lot more
action in it
i saw t1 in the theater when it came out
as a kid we were just [ __ ] blown away
we saw it like a [ __ ] thousand times
watching that thing over and over again
and there's not a lot to t1
um but i think that's what makes it work
it kept it simple it kept it focused
right it was a monster movie a dude it
was focused on her and him
it was a chase yeah you know what i mean
yeah i'm not sure if it would work again
today it was just a
it was just part of the time and then
years later robocop came out i think
that might have been like three years
later and that was 87 i think
that was first robocop yeah that was
bizarre we love robocop
robocop won and robocop 2 was okay too
it was
yeah it wasn't bad the same guy that did
um um he was the same guy that did
empire strikes back
yeah god did that yeah robocop 2 was
good too
but robocop there was something about
robocop one the the timing of it and the
tone
was perfect for that time you just uh
i don't think you're gonna see movies
like that anymore it was another era
you know move movie theaters dominated
the [ __ ] john
you know dominated the media no internet
uh people weren't so jaded when it came
to like imagery
nowadays you could show an image to a
kid and the kid just there's no effect
because they just grew up
seeing fantastic graphics and fantastic
imagery
and it really has no emotional impact
for them
um they don't give a [ __ ] you give them
a video game they like
like it but well because it's immersive
because it's immersive but a movie they
don't really care
which is i think is the reason part of
the reason why you know all this [ __ ]
great reset let's get rid of movie
theaters and amc
and pandemic and all it's because a lot
of these old
things that the ruling class depended on
to make money when obsolete so they
decided to [ __ ] tank it
i think i always see
some kind of motive there you know what
i mean they just did
i could tell by the theater attendance
and when we had
uh amc uh what was the name of that uh
that that
um what was the name of that service we
had we could go see three movies a week
well it was uh a-list
a-list yeah which i liked a-list yeah i
did too i loved it
um and sometimes there were really good
movies on but man the theater was pretty
dead
it's just the theater culture well we
always went like in the middle of the
day like we did
midweek we did for that very reason so
yeah
we did but i mean it's not just my
imagination because they weren't making
very much money and they were
complaining about theater attendance i
mean i was keeping up with this
yeah yeah no they weren't making money
people yeah people weren't seeing them
unless it was something like remember
when we saw [ __ ] john wick three
[ __ ] was packed yeah and we saw this
place
yes well an avengers end game too was
like yeah it was packed
so sounds sold out some of the moves
some feat
some features were just [ __ ] packed
and you knew they were going to be good
before you went
to you know john wick was [ __ ] great
john john all three of those movies
was that four that we saw three it was
three yeah they haven't made a four yet
made it four
although i imagine they probably will
[ __ ] was awesome
tila said she loved the uh dario argento
three mothers trilogy
i love the first two i only saw mother
of tears
can you get me another drink while
you're out yeah yeah give it to him i
mean since you're going out there
check check and see where pookie's at um
i love suspiria one of my favorite
horror movies ever like no contest
um inferno is great too not as good as
superior but
you know a worthy successor i saw mother
of tears
one time on dvd my ex-husband bought the
dvd like this was a long time ago when i
was still married
and i watched it and i remember
not loving it but
i'd be willing to give it another shot
i've been meaning like the last
you know few years i'm like man i should
really watch mother of tears again
because
i remember watching it and just not
liking it because
it seemed like it didn't go with the
other two because it had been such a
long time since they made cesparian
inferno which were only a couple years
apart
i just felt like it didn't have the same
look to it it didn't have the same like
fairy tale
kind of surrealist feel to it i felt
like that but it's been so long since
i've seen it
that i'm not real sure how i would feel
about it now so i definitely do want to
like
re-watch it because i do love cesparian
inferno so
much and i you know i had hoped all
those years that he was gonna make a
third movie like in the three mothers
and then they fight he finally made it
and i
i don't know if it was just because my
expectations were so high and like i
watched it and i was like well that
wasn't really
what i was hoping for you know what i
mean and and the thing about dario
argento too i love dario i do
but after i think the last
movie of his that i really liked
was stendahl syndrome and when the [ __ ]
did that come out
90s early 2000s the one with ozzy
argento in it and like she's chasing
that she's
thanks that [ __ ] still isn't here well
maybe well maybe they just decided to
drive around the truck and they said
[ __ ] it i'm going home
[ __ ] tom yeah he doesn't get his cables
today you'll get them tomorrow just
calm down hold on let me see it should
we sit out for delivery that's just set
out for delivery
well like i said maybe they just drove
i've i've had that [ __ ] happen too where
it says out for delivery and i feel like
they just put it on the truck
and then drove around and were like [ __ ]
it i'm going home i don't really want to
deliver anything today
i'm just going i'm going to bed but yeah
so i think that because
i watched i haven't seen because didn't
he make a movie called
that was just called giallo in i can't
remember what year that was but i
haven't seen that one
but i remember i saw stendhal syndrome
and i really liked that and i
and actually i rewatched that probably
two months ago and i still liked it just
as much
it's that's a good one but then he
started making
like i saw the card player or il carteo
i think it was called an italian
and i hated it
it was so bad and then
um then our friend shawna
who's been on the show before she said
you have to see dario ortiz dracula it's
like so terrible
it was dracula right yeah yeah she's
like it was so terrible that it went all
the way around and became awesome again
so so we watched that one night and it
indeed was very terrible and i was like
man daria what happened to you like
between like the card player which was i
wouldn't say it was like the worst movie
ever but
i mean it was i don't know it just
wasn't great it pissed me off and it's
like i don't know i just i just really
didn't like it and and
after that i was just kind of like man
[ __ ] this i can't believe
that somebody that made such [ __ ]
classics like in the 70s and 80s like
has fallen this far
or whatever and even up into the 90s he
made like some good [ __ ]
but yeah so after the card player i was
kind of thing and then we saw dracula
maybe like a year ago and i'm like wow
this is so
so bad but it was still pretty
entertaining just in how [ __ ] shitty
it was
so i don't know so maybe i was kind of
wrapped up in the hole because i think i
saw mother of tears after i saw the card
player so maybe
the shittiness of the card player kind
of
tainted my i don't know man
making the third movie in the three
mothers trilogy it just seems like
that's some big [ __ ] shoes to fill i
feel like if you're gonna do that
you shouldn't have waited that long one
like until you're like an old person
and then it's so much later that you're
not going to be able to like capture the
same
feel you're not going to be able to i
don't know
it's just i don't know something about
it just didn't sit right with me i guess
and the thing about it is that you can
totally make a modern day giallo movie
[ __ ] we reviewed
that movie the editor that came out in
2014
and that was even that was a parody even
but it's like they got
so much of the [ __ ] right that i just
found it completely [ __ ] delightful
so i don't know i feel like there's no
excuse nowadays
because there's people making modern day
giallos that are like throwbacks to
those i mean look at [ __ ] like the love
witch and stuff like that that where
they
you know she made like a essentially a
60s technicolor movie but it was set in
modern times and so i feel like you
could do that nowadays
so i don't know if you're gonna make the
third of a trilogy i feel like it should
all go together and i just felt like
mother of tears didn't go with the other
two
that's all i'm saying because it had
been such a long time but as i said
it's been probably how long has it been
since i've seen it 10 years 11 years
it's been a while
so i will definitely watch it again but
i did still like the stendhal syndrome
because i was curious about it i
remember i had the dvd like a long time
ago i don't know what happened to it
probably got lost when i moved
but um i remember liking that one and
then i was like
i saw that it was on 2b i think
like a couple months ago and i was like
oh i should rewatch that just
to see if it's still good and i watched
it and i was like oh that is still good
so you know he can still he could still
make good movies at least until the 90s
but i feel like after that
the ones that i saw were just not
although okay i will say though that his
masters of horror
um episodes were pretty good
although i will say that the one that he
did
i think it was season one of masters of
horror it was called jennifer
and it was the one about the woman that
was like she had a weird deformed face
but she was like a
was she a succubus she could even though
she looked like that she could still
like
um she could still like
suck you into like having sex with her
like she had a hot body and everything
but her
face was all [ __ ] up and deformed and
it was
and that was good and i thought did he
do another did he do pelts
help me out here the one with meatloaf
in it where
with the raccoon pelts and like then he
got skinned and [ __ ]
didn't dario agenda direct that too [ __ ]
i don't know i don't have wikipedia open
i seem to remember that he did pelts as
well
and that was also good okay i did a
whole series for my
for my uh blog where i talked about all
the masters of horror episodes
and uh they weren't my favorite ones
but they were still pretty good you know
i feel like the john carpenter one
cigarette burns was my favorite one
that's like the that's the one that i
remember the best that one and the one
with ferris back in it
cookie keeps acting like she wants to go
outside but then she
turns away from the door like she wants
to go outside inside
let's go outside but inside maybe she's
mad because it's cold out it's cold yeah
although usually she likes that i don't
know
is she crazy
she wanted to go outside she's she
specifically likes to go out on the
front porch
the music's gone i turned it way down
because somebody said it was annoying
but
like i said i didn't listen to this
whole [ __ ] playlist i just because i
didn't have time so i just kind of
i'ma hook it up with a better player
list i think
yeah why don't you look at that show me
how to do what i'll do
well you don't have to ship you don't
i'll show you what you can just point me
to it and i can download it and then
i'll put it on next time next time
yeah that's what this was kind of like a
last minute
because you were like oh we should put
some music in the background and i was
like oh [ __ ] now i gotta like [ __ ]
look around for that [ __ ]
um we were talking about hey zach said
farizabak was on an episode of celebrity
ghost stories
yeah i remember it did we see that i
don't remember seeing we saw her
well i know we saw her yeah we saw we
saw her at the
convention yeah we worked with her at
the court at the convention
she was right behind me i didn't was
getting a cup of coffee she was right
behind me and i
i recognized her immediately i didn't
recognize her
she was so skinny she said i didn't look
all that much different
i thought she looked a lot different i
didn't think she looked really thin to
me
well look really thin i didn't recognize
that she was standing right behind me
yeah too thin can't eat
yeah back in the day man i don't know
why
i'm not gonna talk about her back in the
day she had you know she was
normal proportions she was cute but you
know when i saw her lately she was super
foxy
she was too yeah she was too [ __ ]
skinny
yeah i don't remember her being like
inordinately skinny
but i i wasn't looking at her that her
look because i saw her face and i was
like hey that's perez's book
but yeah she was in uh we were talking
about master support
well i was talking about i don't know
but uh
she was in one she was in that one that
was
uh what the [ __ ] was the name of that
pick me up
that was the name of that episode it was
um
two rival serial killers like a trucker
serial killer and a hitchhiker serial
killer
and she was kind of like trapped between
that that was a good episode
a lot of those episodes were good
shudder should bring that [ __ ] back
masters of horror
although i guess it's not it doesn't
have the same
uh kind of like thematic aesthetic
kind of thing like creepshow had you
know what i mean [ __ ] all this [ __ ] man
oh he's putting his [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
man
oh are you going into michael caine mode
[Laughter]
are you is he [ __ ] you i was going to
say that but i thought
is he [ __ ]
[Laughter]
michael king michael that's another
[ __ ] that's two drinks away from
whipping your ass
not even two drinks yeah i wouldn't
think yeah and you know
dude not not really a physical
powerhouse it's just his [ __ ]
face his eyes he did some kind of a
movie
it's crazy strength where yeah he's got
that crazy strength he's scared of going
gotta understand crazy drunks you gotta
understand something
back in the 70s it wasn't really cool
for dudes to work out and get strong you
were just supposed to be
real strong on the strength of your
[ __ ]
man magic you know what i'm talking
about it's like man magic
well if you're worried about that you're
cheating cheating yeah you're cheating
you're working out
yeah you're just supposed to be strong
without that yeah that's [ __ ]
something else
oh so now you want to lift weights you
don't want to get strong yeah
like [ __ ] we don't even need to do that
we have vodka
strong just on the virtue of [ __ ] of
being
me and me you know
i like that better actually no it's not
good i like that better actually yeah
it's called being a pup
that's how every [ __ ] punk takes oh
i'm a punk well that no
i'm i'm
[Laughter]
i was i watched some of these [ __ ]
youtube channels you saw me this morning
i was watching this
youtube channel i don't pay attention to
show you yeah
[ __ ] this girl and girl action they
don't want i was watching
watching this guy his channels call more
plates more dates
he's a [ __ ] chad more plates more
date and more dates more weights that
are on your [ __ ] thing the more dates
you get
i don't think that's true no i think
there's something to it because he's
actually got proof
he's good he's got proof he's got
pictures he's got pictures to prove
he's he photoshopped videos videos
i've seen videos of him i've seen videos
of him
anyway [ __ ] man you [ __ ] me up i
forgot what i was talking about
um he's just [ __ ]
you know he'll lift out videos off of
other people's videos and he's just
going over the average
it was just you go on more plates more
dates than the video he just put up i
think it was
no i guess it might have been from seven
months ago i don't remember when he put
it up you see the recent
seven months i forgot which one it was
and just
this gamer dude was complaining he had
his blood work done
and he's always talking about blood work
that's the good thing is that it's all
science related
they're doing blood tests this dude
knows everything about all these [ __ ]
performances it has everything about
blood
blood and drugs okay and
he's just talking about how some of
these millennial guys their [ __ ]
testosterone levels are [ __ ] [ __ ]
low
single digits double digits [ __ ]
you know it should be like average it's
probably like 750 [ __ ]
was it nanoliters per [ __ ] leader i
forgot what it's called
but a lot of these guys are like at 14
and 15.
and [ __ ] just the [ __ ] funny [ __ ]
i got look at that guy
look at look at how low his testosterone
is you can tell by those
soft kissable lips he's got
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] you can't work
your lips out
what are you the [ __ ] are you even
talking about no
[Laughter]
if a man has a very low testosterone he
was he was young he was in his 20s okay
he didn't even couldn't even really grow
he couldn't even grow a beard
okay and [ __ ] they were saying it
wasn't just him it was his friends too
it was on lines with him but saying that
he had
he had those soft kissable lips
and he did oh no he did he had girl
[ __ ] so you wanted to kiss him
no is that what you're saying that's
what they said yeah okay that's what
they said you see
see this game she's trying to play with
me
oh so you want to kiss no that's what
they said do you know who else had
beautiful kissable lips ian mcculloch
from from uh echoing the bunnymen and he
was
[ __ ] gorgeous yeah but that probably
still is [ __ ] that [ __ ] had
testosterone though
y'all all have testosterone everybody
has testosterone that dude
this dude this dude that he was talking
about he had the blood work
he had the blood work to [ __ ] prove
it he had to take
clomid to try to get his [ __ ] which
is a [ __ ] female
fertility drug he was taking they were
giving him a female fertility drug to
try to kick-start his ew he has to take
female
stuff taking female female [ __ ]
fertility drugs to kick-start his
testosterone dudes crack man
[Laughter]
women he dudes crack me up
hank said hank hill said tom looks like
christopher lloyd
from the adams family film before he
became uncle oh my god yeah
oh my god i forgot all about that oh
[ __ ] scott says blood and drug
shirt that'd be good with blood and
drugs yeah yeah okay
that's a good one tv game says my mom
likes the monkeys badges
i used to love that show that's a little
bit after my time the monkeys but i was
into it they showed it on mtv for some
reason they showed like [ __ ] reruns
of it
badger mentioned that perusa went
through hell on the island of dr moreau
she was at her cutest really wait did i
even see it was that the one with
[ __ ]
marlon brando yeah she was so [ __ ]
cute and he was like they
didn't they have to like bring him in on
a crane or something she was cute in
american history x too
she's just cute in general she's cute in
general
i like her teeth yeah she's got this
real [ __ ] aggressive looking mouth
like she's gonna bite you
i know i'm into that yeah see that's
what i'm saying it's like i don't
i i you know i don't care if it's a dude
or a woman or whatever it's like
i like people that are interesting
looking
scott ryan and she's lips like sugar
lips like sugar
i like that seriously echoing the
bunnymen you guys echoing the bunnyman
that was the first
band that i saw live 1987
at the bob carr auditorium here in
orlando which is not there anymore
or it's i think it's still there but
it's called something else but um
tina says the more tom talks laughing
the more tom talks
yeah i don't know maybe she's making fun
of me again
we're all making it funny we're all
making funny i'm just trying to get i'm
just trying
i'm just kidding oh you get mad
but yeah echo in the binding was the
first live band uh that i saw
i was joined oh i'm looking at myself
and says yeah i'm ready for that
are you ready for that zebra yeah hey
hey mama said the way you move
for some reason uh you know what i
didn't like led zeppelin back in the day
you know what when i was in high school
do you remember in the late 80s early
90s
how it was very this is really weird i
don't know if people remember this
but you know how like right before
grunge came in and [ __ ] like that
there was a big like 60s resurgence
because i feel like a lot of
kids in my high school in the late 80s
were all into led zeppelin and the doors
pink floyd everyone had [ __ ]
long hair and tie-dye kind of [ __ ]
it was kind of that kind of [ __ ] going
on i wasn't involved but i had some
friends that were into that filthy
tom looks really interesting right now i
don't know if it is
because because i said i like
interesting looking people i think she i
think he's farting with me
he needs a man
[Laughter]
are you flirting with sounds
would you [ __ ] me i'd [ __ ] me
tom should be sitting on a cloud with a
bow and arrow
that's what fort jordan down said you
guys that bit my drink up my nose
yeah she's getting sloppy
well i wasn't expecting somebody to say
that when i was taking it
i gotta revert back to it now gotta
revert
goddamn sexual tyrannosaurus
he couldn't take having long curly hair
now he has to go way back in the other
direction
no it's like but you know what my first
um
my first crush when i was a kid i think
was lurch from adam's family
like the original alert and then when i
got older
i know this is weird but like you know
who i was i was really into
like in the 80s i was really into jeremy
irons
and uh john malkovich
i don't know like i liked really weird
looking dudes
tila's in there [ __ ] fantasizing
about jim morrison
jim morrison was pretty hot back in the
day yeah you know he also had very
kissable lips
i i [ __ ] loved the doors the doors
are [ __ ] awesome they were almost
kind of like a proto-gothic band oh
definitely and
they did things they did things almost
kind of with a [ __ ] goth sensibility
from
from that time very late 60s
um but i saw some
back in the days that you know this is
the 80s and we know
that [ __ ] in high school when i
discovered the doors
it was better not really to see him it
was better just to [ __ ] listen to the
tapes and the albums
later on like recently in the past
couple years i dug up a lot of [ __ ]
film
archive film the [ __ ] jim morrison in
action
man you know almost kind of like a
little bit of a letdown
it's like you're ruining it
because i don't want to say it was
it was another time it was another time
and uh
he kind of came off through his body
language you know
uh of a little bit of a charlatan like
he was pretending
and he was also drunk as [ __ ] well he's
like
drunk as [ __ ] and pretending uh which
smug i think is always kind of i always
i always got like a small yeah he got a
smug but you know what though is that it
didn't seem it seemed kind of artificial
to me i could also detect that he was
real uncomfortable
that he had a little bit of stage fright
around people and that he was
kind of under pressure to act out but
that's pretty common though
with performers of that caliber
especially
well we're looking at it in hindsight
at the time he was just
kind of new to the scene he'd only been
doing it for a couple years
and um
[Music]
he was just a dude he was just a dude
trying to make a living yeah he was
doing [ __ ] he was not the legendary jim
morrison that we know that happened
after he died
[Music]
that's kind yeah so it he doesn't have
the gravitas and you could tell he's not
taking himself that seriously he's a
little bit
uh self-conscious and he's not real
totally secure what he's doing
i would say the only dude that really
got to that level
back in those days who was a legend and
knew was the legend at that time with
the bet elvis
yeah elvis was very comfortable with who
he was and what he was doing he knew he
was the king
and then later on in his [ __ ]
vegas phase when when his career was
kind of winding down because he had his
hardcore fan base but he couldn't
compete with the rolling stones and the
beatles
just and he didn't want to up update his
act
he goes backwards into [ __ ] gospel
music
well yeah it's a new era and it's like i
don't know you know if you don't want to
do that
you can't really like be genuine yeah
you know
he he didn't want to do that so what he
does he goes backwards into gospel music
which i get that i get he ends up in
[ __ ]
in in uh vegas drunk as [ __ ] on all
those damn [ __ ]
painkillers they tried to take that [ __ ]
from him he'd pull a gun on you if you
try to take his drugs probably
yeah he called it medicine his
medication
i guess it was in a sense it was
prescription
does [ __ ] doctor what's that poo
[Music]
those doctors should have been [ __ ]
charged
those doctors should have been [ __ ]
criminally charged that was the same
[ __ ] they did the prince
yeah it's [ __ ] criminal and i think
they did that to [ __ ] jackson too
he was on a bunch of prescription drugs
what weren't they they're drug dealers
drug dealers of the stars yeah well it's
kind of the thing where you just have to
find a like slightly disreputable doctor
who
is just willing to give you whatever you
want right
for money yeah you know what i mean well
oh you're elvis i guess that's i guess
you know what you're talking about here
you go here's your perkadan
or whatever well i mean they're just
like everybody else it's like if
somebody's willing to pay you like an
obscene amount of money
[Music]
and you've got this you've got the [ __ ]
then
well it was sad because i was but
in the case of elvis had he not fallen
to
drug addiction had he kind of just laid
low
and adapted to the [ __ ] 60s
i think he could have eventually come
back
and competed with the rolling stones and
um
and the beatles well because i feel like
the early 80s
were kind of a heyday of um
kind of a resurgence of rockabilly yeah
he could so he could have yeah he could
have kind of
come back as the stray cat positioned
himself
you know within that with you know the
cramps and the stray cats and the pole
cats and all that kind of daily idol
right all that kind of stuff you could
have totally pulled that off he could
have had he added kind of the darker
elements of
[ __ ] the rolling stones which really
i love the beatles of that era i
understand the context of the time
the stones were actually i think a
little bit better i'm just saying
the stones were harder the the
i liked that they were more experimental
they were they were all both good that
was almost kind of like the pink floyd
of the 60s
it's hard to pick they're too completely
different they had two completely
different tapes had
had elvis just watched
and put a little bit of rolling stones
in his act
and maybe been able to kind of conceive
of slightly of what was going to happen
with the
with the advent of punk rock because a
lot of people don't know this but very
early rolling stones before they were
famous sounded like punk rock
it did uh they were when they were in
the day well i mean look at [ __ ]
like your pro your proto punk like the
stooges and the mc5 and [ __ ] like that
yeah which you know that was kind of
comparable to like with the rolling
stones
it was conceivable had elvis been
healthy by the time
71 and 70 had rolled around he could
have come up with something that would
have sounded almost like billy idol i
think
yeah imagine him doing something like
something along the lines of white
wedding
yeah see that would have been fantastic
[ __ ] right you imagine like
elvis early 80s there was a big 50s
throwback like a lot of people were
getting back into rockets a lot of punk
rock was rockabilly
therefore and also it's speeded up
rockabilly and it also
and it's also it's also it's also
speeded up
reggae that too it's reggae too because
of scott
yeah speeded up reggae yeah and punks
listening to
punk rockers listen to [ __ ] reggae
yep reagan's got
yep so um conceivably by
71 elvis could have [ __ ] come up with
something along the lines
of a dark mississippi southern [ __ ]
rock that would have been
kind of like a billy i like imagine
white wedding yeah because i feel like a
lot of people
imagine if he did flesh for fantasy yeah
see and
because idol was a copy of elvis that
was a punk rock incarnation
of elvis that's why i love billy island
he's a [ __ ] he
i i admire him as an artist i like him
as a dude
he seems like a good dude he's a good
dude he's he has
drug problems too yeah but a lot of
people
i don't i don't judge it's not a moral
thing it's just like i said
i don't i don't i love nick cave he had
horrible horrible problems with heroin i
don't see
that in in in idol i don't see
i don't i'm not looking at this as some
kind of a moral fault and we're looking
at it more of a professional hindrance
because they could have produced more
and better stuff without it i don't
think it helped them
i don't think it helped their
productivity
i'll go check the door but um yeah i
would have loved to have seen
together elvis in 1970s doing something
kind of like punk rock
somebody said somebody uh somebody said
the police were also kind of considered
punk
which they were i remember that well i
had a lot of sky influence
oh yeah big time that that was a big
reiki implement please i i love the
police actually the first
album that i spent my own money on was
synchronicity yeah
when i was 11. and i [ __ ] wore
that album out a lot of a lot of that's
a great album
a lot of americans don't understand the
the
uh the crossover between punk rock
reggae and rap there was a lot of
crossover
well everything that wasn't mainstream
music at the time
they all hung out we all kind of hung
out together i mean i hung out with
kids that were into punk i hung out with
new wave kids i hung out with reggae
kids
you just hung out with all the outsider
people
england didn't have african americans
african-americans aren't africans that
are in america
right but they had jamaican people that
were jamaican
of jamaican background and they had
reggae they could
back in the days of [ __ ] punk rock in
the 70s they
hated they hated prague rock the punk
rock kids would not listen to prog rock
yeah it was so the only choice that they
had on the [ __ ] jukeboxes
was reggae yeah so then they started
playing reggae
and that became [ __ ] kind of like the
specials and [ __ ] uh
the jam the jam and to the lesser right
so there was some cross over there and
even the english beat
the clash had sky rift rifts in it and
[ __ ]
even bauhaus did like some [ __ ] that had
some yeah
reggae influence right which was
unmasked yeah
now back in the united states [ __ ]
punk rock came to america and it was not
really understood that
very much at the time it took a while
for that to set in and then billy idol
and all these other guys started to come
over
malcolm mclaren came over to the united
states
and they found out that their version of
jamaicans or our version of jamaicans
are african-americans
and malcolm mclaren found the [ __ ]
bands
out out in out in uh new york i think it
was new york or chicago i don't remember
i think it might have been new york
and he just he noticed something that
today you would call rap
yeah and he said this is gonna be
the next new thing and malcolm mclaren
tried to capitalize on rap
and i think one of the bands that he got
involved with did buffalo girls which is
like one of the very first
remember that oh girls that go around
yeah
yeah
and and that was kind of like a rap
adjacent thing
and then there was musical youth but
that was jamaican
i think yeah yeah that was 82
i want to say yeah uh all of a sudden
rap acts the early rap acts started well
and look [ __ ] even blondie in rapture
that rap yeah did [ __ ] have five
freddie and [ __ ] yeah
and this is one of the first american
bands to do that yeah
so a lot of people don't really
understand the history of all this [ __ ]
there was a lots and lots of [ __ ]
ethnic crossover
during all that and a lot of the [ __ ]
real
even in england and in the united states
a lot of these that [ __ ] came off as
being white as [ __ ] and it wasn't as
wide as you think it was
that scene was well as i said it was
just kind of like
outsiders all grouping together
like we're all outsiders so we're kind
of gonna
mango said madness remember madness i
love that [ __ ] madness was awesome
i love madness yeah i love all that [ __ ]
taylor knows about malcolm and buffalo
girls yeah remember that's
how old are you taylor
i love when somebody knows the history
because i'm super into like the history
of
punk and post punk and stuff because i'm
like a big you know music person and
it's like i love
buffalo girls i love all that [ __ ] kind
of like a mixture of industrial and rap
that was what 1982 maybe
it might have been yeah maybe earlier
buffalo girls going around the outside
around the outside running dosing dirty
apart and they were and it was just a
mix
they were doing [ __ ] square dance it
was they lifted a track off a squared
ass [ __ ] song
and mixed that in with a bunch of other
scratching and all kinds of stuff
because malcolm mclaren saw black dudes
scratching
yeah and he was just like that's [ __ ]
fantastic and they were doing it
in a burned out ruins of i think chicago
i think it was
he was chicago and new york yeah i mean
a lot of that [ __ ] came out of new york
i feel like because you got like the
whole
you got your new wave [ __ ] you know you
had cbg we said blondie you had talking
hedge all that
then you had your no wave yeah you know
you had like swans throbbing bristle you
had all that kind of [ __ ] going on too
that was like a new york thing
and then a [ __ ] harmony house karen
which was a girl that [ __ ]
my butt remember uh steve he's not dr
steve
when we were kids this was that in
michigan he was banging this [ __ ]
girl who's like four or five years older
than us
and she worked at harmony house and she
would give him all these [ __ ] albums
all right free at free album she was
older than us she was
kind of like our hip connection she'd
give us free tickets and [ __ ]
and looking back on it the [ __ ] was
probably illegal so i think she might
have been about 20.
we were like 17 or so and
one of the albums that she gave steve
steve says hey ross you might like this
one man and it was an
album i've never [ __ ] seen it before
and it had these [ __ ] it was a spooky
dark room
with these [ __ ] sinister looking
black dudes with [ __ ] black berets
and [ __ ]
black glasses on and it was this i
didn't know what it was it was called
public enemy man the album was called
yo bum rush the show
[ __ ] loved it i [ __ ] looked had my
uzi weighs a ton on it
they had [ __ ] 98 oldsmobile i had all
these
and and that was like the beginning of
[ __ ] gangster rap
and i was in on that when it first
[ __ ] came out
it was different back then because you
could tell that it was homemade
that it was made by these guys this
wasn't some corporate [ __ ]
i [ __ ] loved it [ __ ]
and then i saw flame and pictures of
flame and i said what the [ __ ] is this
dude all about
and then soon after that you could get
like
underground music videos of public enemy
with flavor flav
and he had a huge [ __ ] clock hanging
around his neck
and it was all this symbolism and stuff
you know is i [ __ ] loved it man i
[ __ ] loved it it was just like
black nationalism black nationalism
brought to
and it was kind of industrial it kind of
fit in
at the time it sounded a little bit like
skinny puppy
well yeah because i knew a lot of black
skinny puppies yeah a lot of people that
were into industrial were into that too
there wasn't like a
it's weird because i mean i don't know
it might have been different
um in different areas like i grew up
kind of in the south
so you know there wasn't a lot of people
that were into
punk or post-punk or anything like that
so everybody that was into
something i guess you would call like
outsider music that wasn't like
mainstream music
they all kind of hung out together so
you kind of got like reggae people you
got punk people you got industrial
people
you'd all kind of like hang out together
so you don't like listen to each other's
music there wasn't like a lot of
there wasn't a lot of click kind of [ __ ]
going on
i know in other places there was because
i've heard other people that
grew up other places that have talked
about it's like oh the punks don't like
new waivers and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
but where i grew up there was so few of
us that
we just we all had to hang out together
because what there was like five or six
of us maybe
like in the school so it's like you kind
of had to like against the jocks and
cheerleaders
you know the mainstream culture you kind
of had to you know hey you're into
throbbing gristle hey i'm into
you know i'm into whatever i'm into the
swans i'm into this i'm into that
so it's like you know i like the clash i
like this that and the other thing
and it's like so you just kind of had to
all just hang out together
and so everyone just kind of like
learned
to like each other's stuff jesus says
i'm 33 but i was raised right
to know old reviews and appreciate good
music i respect
the and then she goes on
to say that there are younger peeps on
youtube doing the
music reaction videos to older music and
they love it they're getting an
education yeah i've been noticing that
too
i have also been you know what's funny
is i've been watching the reaction
videos it's going
it's going across it's going across
ethnic [ __ ] violence too
you see these [ __ ] uh young black
kids listening to iron maiden from like
80
what is it 82 83 84 and there's oh this
is fantastic see good [ __ ] it's like a
hallow be thy name
and [ __ ] you know yeah because uh
back in those days it's at the
mainstream level
there was a basically kind of like
ethnic boundaries he didn't really have
black dudes back in 83 listening to iron
maiden
but no yeah that wasn't really but now
the cross but now because it's all in
the past there's all kinds of
cultural crossover now but that's good
yeah well yeah of course that but it's
just like
it's funny because i was talking to sod
who's who's
he's from saudi arabia and he's a
subscriber
and i was showing him some music and he
goes yeah
he's like i don't listen to any music i
remember when i was born you know what i
mean
we don't make good music anymore all the
good music was made a long time ago
so because of corporate culture it
destroys everything that it [ __ ]
touches new music isn't no anywhere as
good as it was
in the 80s and the 70s 90s
music was good i mean there's good [ __ ]
out there but you have to like look
for it you got to look forward to it
that's not what's going to be on the
radio
yeah but i feel like that was kind of
the case back then too because
yeah it was a lot of [ __ ] that was on
the radio back then
sucked also exactly and honestly um
you know punk reggae all that kind of
[ __ ]
post punk that was a reaction because i
remember
listening to the radio and like i said
this might be regional in the united
states because i grew up in the south
and
you know we have like a lot of rednecky
stations and [ __ ]
we didn't have any cool like college
stations or anything gainesville they
did
but um because that's like where uf is
the university of florida
yeah but um it was kind of like
in the early 80s the radio stations
where i grew up were still playing
old music they were still playing like
prague rock and 60 stuff
which i like now but at the time in the
early 80s i was like man that's like my
dad's
[ __ ] that's what my dad likes although i
wasn't
that i wasn't that averse to it because
my dad was really into like the beatles
and the doors and i liked that from like
a really young age
but i didn't like all that southern rock
and like all the eagles and [ __ ]
molly hatchet and all that
and it felt like that was because i grew
up in daytona beach and that's
what was on a lot of the radio back then
i didn't like that
yeah you know what i mean i did like the
beatles and the doors and all that but
responded to tila yeah
you know black guys are black people are
now kind of
they're kind of like uh discovering
non-black music from the 80s and looking
at how cool it was
that was good because i lived through
that era
and there was almost kind of like uh
tribal loyalties about who you would
listen to
yeah it was like that you didn't have
black people listening to white music
you had white people listening to black
music that's why you get a lot of the
ideas
yeah yeah even uh billy idol or not
billy uh
david bowie david bowie did a lot of
stuff it was like seoul
and when i was still in high school
because i liked the doors and i liked uh
pink floyd because i liked some prog
rock too i yeah i like to
uh probably on top of some of the early
goth and punk and metal
i started um going way way back and
listening to
blues like muddy waters and howling wolf
and all that i love that chip stuff
and yeah that [ __ ] was real good really
really good
and you know it's just it also just made
sense with
to me being southern you know what i
mean that that's all
very southern music um blues
delta mississippi delta blues yeah
that's
and i like that better a lot better yeah
yeah so here's the thing about southern
rock a lot of southern rock wasn't dudes
from the south
it was fake southern rock well and i
think too when you grow up here
it's just it's so ubiquitous that you
get [ __ ] sick of it
even what well what is southern red even
even even the rolling stones was ripping
off the southern rocks
yeah they were which i respect that
that's okay but
you got americans faking accent
sometimes and some of them are british
yeah wild horses
away you are not southern you are
[ __ ] british
not gonna knock that [ __ ] off it's all
right
[Laughter]
yeah the sundays covered that song did
you know that yeah
in the 90s but uh i'm still going to
give it to
uh i'm still going to give it to the
stones
i love the rolling stones the beatles
might have been more experimental
i grew up with the beatles like ever
since i was a kid
my dad my dad is like the biggest
beatles fan on earth
you guys you don't even know i kind of
think the rolling stones were kind of
the first goth band
to certain too see i don't know i don't
know if i could yeah
like i love the rolling stones i'm not
saying that the rolling stones are
brilliant
but so they have i do feel like the
rolling stones
were just they were reinterpreting
um something that already existed like
you said they they were taking
blues they were taking like pub rock
they were taking all that kind of stuff
and putting their own spin on and making
it brilliant i'm not saying they weren't
brilliant because they were
i feel like the beatles were more
i liked the beatles more because not
only were they great
songwriters like in the sense that they
could write a great song
that would like stick in your head and
was like really memorable
but also they weren't really concerned
about sticking to a particular style
and they're like whatever our influences
are at the moment we're just gonna like
do that
so i i respect more of the like
creativity
you know what i'm saying sophie just
private messaged me
been trying to get into the misfits
figuring out the timeline checking out
the variety of songs because
they're all over the place you ever been
into them or not you're seeing of course
i don't know if she's listening to this
i love the misfits
but um my my brother
who is four years younger than i am uh
he had a punk band
for a time he had one called jello bone
and he had one called dr
evil and they played uh many places
around daytona a few places in orlando
back in the day
like late 80s early 90s he learned to
play
guitar and bass largely by listening to
the misfits and bad religion
so when i was growing up because his
bedroom was right next to mine in the
apartment
so i would so i would hear the misfits
and bad religion through my
wall every day for many many hours i
don't know if sophie's in the stream or
not maybe that was just a random message
do you have it i love it i've seen her i
haven't seen her in there okay
i love the misfits i do i love
i mean if you're going to go with
the misfits i would call what would you
call that horror punk
i guess it was california pop rock yeah
i call it horror punk because it's just
because
every single song was like based on a
horror movie and they named it after
like an old
horror movie and i love that aesthetic
this is why i love the cramps so much
because i love the [ __ ] cramps
um they just they took that old like 50s
aesthetic and like
applied it to 70s 80s
and like made some punk rock [ __ ] out of
it and i love that
i love the misfits more like i don't
know
i love the older [ __ ] i guess
there was just something about that time
it's a weird thing but maybe it was just
us that time no
no it's not it's not i'm gonna tell you
let me tell you
a lot of it had to do with the fact that
in those days
music was our social media
that was our version of the internet
there was no internet well that was how
you related to other people that was how
you do your tribe
there was no there was no hold on
all right let me run in peace yeah okay
and you
you talk right you can take the call if
you want
i'm good the um
we didn't have internet so our social
media was music
so they put more effort in it and the
guys that were
working as musicians and like you want
to call them rock stars whatever
rap stars they actually got more out of
it they got more reward out of it
i mean friends of mine like you know
from a starry night
and uh you know 13th angel which you
know people we work with
and jenny's so many done so many goddamn
black metal album covers it's not fun
these are dudes that
back in the day would have been real
well known they would have been wealthy
they would have been pretty famous but
today they're just competing against
so much other stuff you know they're
competing against video games they're
competing against music
internet social media instagram
there's just not enough time to sit
around
and listen to goddamn albums i mean i
used to go in my room and put an
album on put headphones on just lay on
my back on the damn ground on the floor
with pillow and just sit there and look
at the album cover the album cover was
that was your graphics man that was that
was your music video
sitting there looking at the album and
switching back and reading the lyrics
and some you just
spent all day [ __ ] looking looking at
them records
and record albums it was just another
time it was a
slower time but you you were kind of
savored things more
little things meant more it was a little
more immersive it was more personal
you know i mean i'm sure people in the
uh
in the in the comment sections know what
it is i'm talking about it was just
in some way you know for music it was
definitely a better time that was the
time
for that genre when mtv came out it was
[ __ ] great
but then after about six seven eight
years of [ __ ] mtv
that started to saturate then you
started ignoring that
it's like society gets used to things
this threshold gets hot
well that's like a very human thing yeah
[ __ ] goes on for long enough you just
get used to it it's not cool
yeah and then the internet came out
and i remember in the late 90s [ __ ]
around with early internet
better than today's internet even though
early internet [ __ ] sucked
which i'll explain what it is
was waiting i went to the bathroom which
is right there
and she was outside the door me me me
she peeps when she wants to go outside
she's like you guys i ha i have to go
outside i have to go sit by the tree
yeah she sits by the tree in our
backyard
waiting for that raccoon i guess there
was something kind of charming about
early internet
it didn't have the functionality that it
had today but it kind of had a deeper
more mysterious [ __ ]
vibe to it and it and your mom wasn't on
it
it was just mom and dad moms and
grandma's on that [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
mainstream it's like
and i mean i'm like people's mom's age
too
which i get that but i'm not anyone's
mom except for pookie but
um i still kind of feel like oh man my
mom's on this [ __ ]
so i i still kind of have that mentality
anybody can use it and and it was harder
to use back then you had to kind of had
to have some computer skills to get [ __ ]
done you didn't know how to format hard
drives
remember formatting your hard drive
doing formatting your operating system
and [ __ ]
i i forgot what it was i mean we
remember
back when there was no windows you just
you had to like write your own little
yeah program well when windows first
started to come out was a lot easier
though
well yeah that is a lot easier yeah
internet connections and stuff and then
you have like
internet lore and strange [ __ ]
if you youtube channel wang explains a
lot of that [ __ ]
i mean i remember the internet of the
90s i remember a lot of it
it was more mysterious and it was in a
way more powerful it seemed like it was
more powerful because it was had fewer
people on it
yeah because only people yeah only
people that were kind of like
yeah tech savvy i guess right
radar saying [ __ ] and talking and
trading
and it was the wild west you could order
something illegal over the internet well
you can still do that you can still do
it
to be fair it was a lot easier you just
have to be sneakier
and and average [ __ ] joe didn't have
any idea how to use it
now anybody can do it scott says pookie
won't accept your facebook request
that would not surprise me no pokey's
nice
she would accept our facebook request i
feel like maybe
i don't know though we're her parents
she might not think we're cool
not really sure
[Music]
but yeah so like
[Music]
man yeah xanada says it was mysterious
it was oh yeah and [ __ ] tv knows
about dial up
you [ __ ] try to connect to the
internet and it made this budgie
[Music]
in violation of all these other
[ __ ] and then 20 minutes later
somebody's like i need to use the phone
get off that [ __ ]
and it took forever for [ __ ] they
didn't have [ __ ] uh streaming
they didn't really have streaming yeah
and [ __ ] porn it took forever it was
just photographs
well it was just line by line you're
like come on titties that's her face i
don't give a [ __ ] about her face
yeah and then go to the next one where
are the nipples where's the bush come on
come on it took so long delayed
gratification
yeah like the hottest porn star on the
web was the dude named [ __ ]
was done dude a chick named danny ashe
you said dude first
you know why because i've seen the
daniel ash
from [ __ ] from uh i'll allow it
what's that
love and rocket
although ash i love daniel lash but i'm
gonna say
danny ash was a point was a [ __ ] girl
on the internet she was [ __ ] big
boobs big blonde
and she had a she [ __ ] howard stern
kept plugging
plug in her [ __ ] site it was called
daddy's hard drive
nothing but just busty beauties on that
but it was
by today's standards this [ __ ] was
[ __ ] r-rated
but back in the day that was that was
some [ __ ]
well yeah you couldn't just see anything
yeah you couldn't see nowadays you'd go
on the internet and just like
look i'd like a video of someone
stepping on someone's nuts
with a high heel shoe yeah kicking a
dude in the balls remember we saw that
woman today
yeah people stick in their balls dudes
sticking their balls through a hole in
like a plank or something yeah
somebody else stepping up and then she
has a high heel shoe and she just like
squishes them and stuff
i like that you got to watch it with
these women
because the women are like yeah they're
just doing it weird [ __ ] stepping on
dudes [ __ ] nuts and [ __ ] and then
trying to put it with it it's very
cathartic
trying to [ __ ]
it's not so much that it's just that i
think that
girls are so used to um
dudes being like in charge of everything
and like running everything
so it's nice to see them kind of laid
low i guess
you know what i mean so i'm saying you
gotta watch of those women man
oh yeah we'll lay you low we'll [ __ ] you
up yeah they'll [ __ ] yeah
well hey y'all shouldn't be that way
we wouldn't we wouldn't feel the need to
do that and [ __ ] to you
z zannit is going tom is nostalgic the
same way i feel about the 90s
the 90s i don't like the 90s
i liked the 80s the 90s um
i was kind of over it by that point i
was kind of like yeah i'm not so sure i
like this decade
i like the 90s the 90s was a
transitional period
it was like the 80s but it was high tech
you
knew that it was flipping over into an
online world because it was starting to
come you had [ __ ]
you had internet not everybody but it
was out there
it was slow but for the day it was very
powerful
and you were just like man i'm in a bra
i'm in a whole new world
it hadn't set in yet though the rest of
the world was very
80s very yeah tangible was not an online
world
just you yeah you know you're in there
and you're like oh yeah
and the whole idea of wireless internet
really [ __ ] tripped me up with cell
phones that could go on the internet
and it started off with laptops that
could go on the internet without any
wires
i was tripping when i first saw that i
was like think of the possibilities
and it's here now i've been here [ __ ]
tesla [ __ ]
and now it's just like [ __ ] everybody
takes for granted take it for granted
now
which is i think that may be why
you know i like the 80s i wouldn't go
back there um i like a lot of the music
from that i like the music from then
um and the movies from then but i don't
i wouldn't go back there because there's
a pain in the ass
but the 90s i don't feel a lot of
nostalgia for
i like the 80s and i like now i liked
the 90s i mean i was
i don't like all that transitional oh
we're kind of like in between it's like
i don't feel any nostalgia for that
because you weren't there you weren't
there where was i you weren't there with
me
it was just my the perspective my
perspective
it it was a good time for me
i guess i mean i was
late 20s you know late 20s well i was
early 20s in the 90s
i graduated from high school in 1990 so
i was 18
19 you had internet
new music was coming it's very positive
time
um you had cute girls
wearing jenko jeans and [ __ ] tongue
rings
[Laughter]
in the mall you still had malls you know
i didn't like malls in the 80s so you
know
that that was it was just malls [ __ ] i
mean i had mall culture
it was uh it was a weird mixture
of the modern world and the and the old
world of like the 80s
i didn't you don't i didn't know it at
the time that it was a mixture of two
different worlds
but looking back on it was yeah that's
something you would only see in
hindsight yeah
it was it was in between both and
um just there was something about the
people
of the time they were very positive they
were easy to deal with you didn't you
weren't dealing with
weird [ __ ] negative [ __ ] aspects
of them you know what i mean that you
see
now um it's just
i'm just just saying it was a fun time
we didn't have social media so you could
pretend
that like your friends were cool and not
like complete [ __ ] that were like
just
trolling people and being [ __ ] on
the internet is that what you're saying
no not at all
[Laughter]
i'm just saying that it was a simpler
time it seemed like people were kind of
innocent
and they were going into a [ __ ]
bigger world for the first time
people that for instance like i was in
mississippi when i went to mississippi
after being in boston kids in
mississippi
or kid i'm calling kids now but you know
the young people in mississippi
in their 20s we're [ __ ] wearing
jinkos in the mall with [ __ ] tongue
rings and [ __ ]
going to hot topic and they had the
[ __ ] internet at home they didn't
have it on
on cell phones in their pocket but they
had internet at home
and they were real friendly and they
were easy to hook up with and they just
was it was a good time
and they looked hot everybody looked hot
back then it just did
to me when you were there at the time
well after the mom jeans thing
faded yeah mom jeans were gone that
helped a lot because
the cool girls were you guys cool girls
were wearing jinkos
and they were hit huggers they were real
low and they were [ __ ] big it was
like a skirt
they went all the way down the ground
had [ __ ] but it had like pant legs
gigantic ridiculous [ __ ]
all right they were but but they [ __ ]
had tong rigs and pierced nipples and
better than mom james yeah i will say
that tongue rings
pierce nibbles [ __ ] yeah that was a
big thing yeah
[ __ ] belly shirts oh yeah they're
[ __ ] just right here
[ __ ] colored beads [ __ ] colored
glasses the lenses were colored they're
[ __ ]
like pink or something i guess i didn't
like here's what i didn't like about the
90s
i didn't like because i feel like the
80s
what i liked about the 80s was that
you had a very clear distinction between
there was the mainstream [ __ ] which
sucked
and then you kind of had like
underground [ __ ] and that was like that
could be anything it was it was like a
big wide like i said it was kind of like
back in the 80s whether you were into
industrial you were into punk you were
under reggae you were in a
you know hip hop whatever all those
people hung out together and that was
cool but like the mainstream didn't know
about it
the 90s i feel like everybody knew about
it
and it became corporatized yeah um
you know hot topic started selling all
this like look it's alternative clothing
and that pissed me off i just described
it that pissed me off because it ruined
it
it ruined it well it depends
that's what i did i just i just i just
described it
goths didn't look the way i just
described the way i just described with
the [ __ ] jenkos and the belly [ __ ]
shirts and all [ __ ] that was
more of a mainstream type type of thing
that's what irritated us but
i thought it looked good it was co-opted
i thought it looked that wasn't goth to
me though
no and then later they [ __ ] used
black clothes
they would take that take the same look
and just turn the clothes black and they
were gravers
which i [ __ ] liked that too but then
you gotta understand my perspective is
very different than yours because i was
i was a young guy i'm just trying to hit
i don't [ __ ] really care about
[ __ ] you know
i wasn't really like that you don't care
about anything important
that was the priority that was the
priority if they were cute
then [ __ ] you're good to go the um
i preferred [ __ ] girls from the goth
[ __ ] community
but a lot of times they were [ __ ] too
difficult to deal with
a lot of them had mental problems it
just depended what the situation some of
them had drug problems too
i mean in in some of those scenes
[ __ ] you know there was still a
[ __ ] there was still a heroin
hangover and there was so i never got
into that but yeah there was a lot of
that in the enemies
when i was in boston a good 25 percent
of them were still
junkies so you're not gonna [ __ ] with
that there were a lot of punks
and then a lot of them were [ __ ]
college students you didn't want to [ __ ]
with that because their heads were full
of [ __ ]
um they were dumb
uh so you were looking for
you were looking for local girls from
boston not college students
and you were looking for ones that were
old enough to know the deal they weren't
under the protection of their families
still
so in that scene that i'm talking about
what that ended up being most of the
time in the gossip was a stripper
stripper yeah okay a god stripper
so that's what happened remember i told
you about vadim russian the russian soul
ex-soldiers to hang out with yeah
he was a creation of a [ __ ] local
goth stripper
and you know a lot of the girls that
[ __ ] in the scene today that we hang
out they're strippers
skippers i will admit it's a good way to
make money yeah
so you know that was the deal
i don't blame people for doing that not
i'm just i'm just telling the truth
i couldn't do that but that's just true
because i have issues i'm not gonna do
that
but you know what i mean i could see if
if you're hot enough [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] i don't blame you
but i'm just saying that i think that
me growing up in the 80s and really
being into
the whole 80s punk and new wave type of
scene
from the early 80s i got to reset this
[ __ ] man and that was something that i
was like really into and that was
something that my
i guess my identity was kind of tied to
if you want to say it like that
so when the 90s came along and like all
these stupid [ __ ] who i had
hated
previously we're now suddenly oh i'm
saying
like yeah i'm so into this and that
and it just honestly it just kind of
annoyed me
so i think that was kind of like so
i think like a lot of my favorite music
kind of stops at like 1992
because after 1992 i stopped watching
i stopped like listening to new music i
stopped kind of like i was like man [ __ ]
that [ __ ] it's like
everybody you know after nirvana hit
and here's another funny thing i
remember
seeing and i vividly remember this i
remember seeing the video
for smells like teen spirit in 1991 i
guess it came out
i remember seeing that video on
120 minutes which if you don't remember
was like the
use their alternative video show that
they show it was like at midnight like
on sunday night
from midnight to 2 a.m and that was like
where they showed all their alternative
music they didn't usually show it during
the day that was like the only time that
they showed it was
these two this two-hour block like
sunday night
so i remember seeing that song and i was
like man that's a that's a pretty good
song i don't see that ever
getting popular or anything like that
shows what i know um
and then a couple days later i saw that
video
you know in the middle of the afternoon
and then suddenly it just went [ __ ]
it was everywhere and i think after that
happened
i became really i was talking about
smells like teen spirit no
i remember that happening
because i remember specifically seeing
that song before anybody had heard it
and being like man that's you know
that's pretty good i can't really see
that getting popular because at this
point there was like some inkling that
[ __ ] that had been underground for the
past decade or whatever
was kind of threatening to go mainstream
everyone was kind of like nervous about
it i guess i was nervous about it
so i was like man that you know i don't
think that would ever get like super
popular and
then like literally a day or two later
that song was on mtv like in the middle
of the afternoon
and then suddenly it just went it just
went [ __ ] everywhere and that
[ __ ] album was everywhere that
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] and it was just like this
whole thing and i think that really like
disillusioned me because i think i
liked it better when it was just
i don't know i i liked it better when it
was a more community based thing
like it was a more underground thing it
was like you know we're
because seriously i got the first
nirvana that
i got that nirvana out i got bleach and
i got never mind
from a friend of mine who just pirated
them for me he's like hey this is pretty
cool like check that then he just gave
like with a bunch of other pirated
albums because that's what we did we
just recorded them for each other
yeah because everyone was broke so i
kind of got it and then i used to listen
all this oh this is a good album you
know
whatever i used to listen to it
sometimes so i was like you know
cleaning the house or whatever
and so the fact that that was gone now
i don't know that really like that
really bummed me out
this is the comments here that's going
on
rick shaw said nirvana really did blow
up overnight it really didn't it's like
i felt like i was remembering it wrong
because
i was kind of like dude i literally saw
that video
on 120 minutes you know like i said
which was not a mainstream show that was
it was like it's sunday night from
midnight to 2 a.m and i used to watch it
every week i used to record it actually
filthy garden says i don't like them now
because of the madness for all the from
all the ridiculous crazy opinion
pains on the internet and then yeah but
everybody's had stupid opinions forever
and you just didn't know about them
before
that's what he means it was easier
that's what he's saying that's what he's
saying
but that's kind of what i tell myself
but i i mean i liked back then
because it was a time before that
yeah but i like now because everything's
so much easier
it looks like tila's leaving no oh don't
go yeah xanada says the world was still
local back then not
international and then victor says we
definitely trolled people in the chat
rooms in the 90s chat rooms with the
[ __ ]
there was all kinds of [ __ ] that was
going on in chat rooms and you'd be like
being only like five or six people in
the damn chat room
fighting over and you would be making
things up over there it was [ __ ]
then one of them would be like a sexual
predator or a pedophile or something and
you didn't even know back then
no no they had this weird [ __ ] thing
was called irc
i don't remember all the stuff i knew i
was there too and then you had like
[ __ ] um i also had web tv
web tv was better at the house but
[ __ ] you'd have
internet at the office through a pc and
later on i had a [ __ ] pc it didn't
have internet it was just a weird [ __ ]
but i i had [ __ ] web tv and then they
had web tv chat rooms too
it was just another time and uh
we met there was all kinds of weird [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] going there it was
funny
you know none of that [ __ ] was serious
the internet in those days
was very uh upbeat i thought
i just thought it was very upbeat it was
funny and i think
that could have just been what you were
yeah because it was a small it was small
scale yeah it was very small scale
so it was more of a personal experience
and it was
just more it was just more of a game you
know
i'm just i kind of feel like nowadays
you know it's very fun like people don't
mean this to be taken seriously but a
lot of people say look the internet was
a mistake
i don't think it was because that's like
what my whole work comes from now
but i'm just saying that
i think it was easier back in the day
because
like shitty people existed still as they
have existed throughout
entire human history but you didn't know
about it
now you know about it because every
stupid [ __ ] is posting
stupid [ __ ] on social media says didn't
they have the heroin
sheep models from the 90s yes they did
they did that was a big thing
yeah and uh oh they were so skinny tom's
going off now that's the 90s i remember
and then zach says isn't the cam girl
the modern stripper yes
the model yeah it's essential but it's
much safer
but back honestly back in the day a
stripper was
was a real stripper they were up there
stripping and uh
a lot of them were somebody said wait a
minute golf strip club where
now rick we're talking about man ray
which is gone that's in boston
and it was a normal goth club what was a
really good goth club
for the day it's just that a lot of the
girls that didn't fit the profile of
what i was saying in other words they
weren't
junkies and they weren't college
students
and they were hot but they weren't
college students or [ __ ]
or [ __ ] junkies we're strippers
well like that's who's hanging out if
you're hot it's a pretty decent way to
make money yeah
and like i said i would not [ __ ] on
anybody for first
year in the night in the 90s
um being in my 20s i just would not date
a college girl
back in those days not in not in because
you know it was the [ __ ] cuz you
don't like smart girls
no you had to see them but you had to
see him and understand what the [ __ ]
deal was
they weren't smart either just like all
the other ones
they just uh they were just [ __ ]
[Music]
one they didn't have money all right
they didn't have money
two they didn't understand normal
problems like
having to go to work in the morning you
know what i mean and [ __ ]
they just weren't practical they were
still kind of like a high school girl
that's the way they were well i feel
like college that's kind of like an
extension of heights yeah they were just
like they were like high school girls
they were not realistic
in any way and they were [ __ ] spoiled
blood spoiled
and they only spent their parents money
they didn't make their own money
and i'm and this is boston so we're
talking
harvard tufts mit [ __ ]
uh umass boston these are [ __ ] rich
people
all right and back in those days rich
[ __ ] goth girls [ __ ] college girls
would [ __ ] pay the ass they're full
[ __ ]
well i feel like rich people in general
were kind of a pain in there and then
you had
[Music]
you had girls that [ __ ] actually had
jobs they were cool
but a lot of them just you know i mean
they just a lot of them
i didn't find really attractive the
attractive ones that had jobs
in that particular scene at that time
were strippers
those were the [ __ ] you know
and even nowadays like in the past
in our scene they're strippers or cam
girls we've known some cam girls and
honestly if you can make a living doing
that
[ __ ] man more power to you because
honestly being a stripper
or being a sex worker is dangerous still
um but working as a cam girl
you get all the perks of that you get a
bunch of dumb
suckers like giving you money which
awesome um but also
you're in the comfort of your own home
and hopefully none of these dumb [ __ ]
find out where you live and can stalk
you
rick shaw is asking what's a chat room
and then he laughs though so i guess he
knows what a chat he knows
chat room man [ __ ] dude you missed it
it was [ __ ] ridiculous oh i thought
tila left she's still here
oh okay i thought she was she was gonna
say goodbye to somebody else oh okay
in in that way i feel like even though a
lot of people like [ __ ] on the internet
in general um i
i think it's been you know yeah there's
a lot of bad things about it
obviously but i think the only bad
things about it
are bad things that were always present
in human society that we're just aware
of now that we weren't aware
my friend khan of austin said in mexico
we didn't have internet homes until 97.
actually that's not far off uh i would
probably say around 97 is about when
i we got our first pc that had
internet in 95 and it was dial-up
it was super super slow by the time 97
rolled around
in the united states you could do what i
did and
for like a hundred and thirty dollars by
a web tv hook it up to your tv put it in
your phone line and get [ __ ]
internet for 20 bucks a month and that
was the
easiest way into the internet and it
didn't make a difference
i liked it better than the pc it
couldn't get a viruses or anything like
that you didn't worry about operating
systems
um and it made sense in those days for
that particular bit of time
because there wasn't much on the
internet anyway it wasn't as
data rich as you that wouldn't work
today
um and now costs have gone down
for pcs and laptops
it was just very expensive back then and
[ __ ] was updating so quickly
that web tv was a good deal for a couple
years we never had that i think we
got internet in we got dial up in i
think 1995 or 1996
and it was super super slow we didn't
use it for
much of anything except for email we
played video games up there mostly on
dvd
scott ayan says he used to hang out the
middle east which is right across the
street from man race so my friend yep
i remember the middle east the middle
east was awesome that was down there
near
what was it called what's the name of
that [ __ ] t-stop there
central i think it was central oh it was
on i think it was on the green line
you had the middle east and then right
next to the middle east you had the
indian restaurant i used to eat there
all the time
and then you get on that [ __ ] same
road and head towards harvard square
remember remember the old house of blues
with the dungeon downstairs used to love
the dungeon you used to hang out the
dungeon
i used to hang out [ __ ] man ray and i
used to hang out the [ __ ] rat skeller
with all the [ __ ]
process remember the rat skeller place
is [ __ ] awesome
trying to think where else i used to
hang out those are my main hangouts
but um he knows how boston is boston was
like
new york but for rich people
it was [ __ ] although i feel like new
york was kind of for rich people too
yeah
you can't really afford to live well you
can't afford to live in manhattan only
yeah yeah only in manhattan was for the
rich people it was a little
i like here's the difference though
boston in general you had two
[ __ ] modes either they were cool as
[ __ ] or they were
[ __ ] [ __ ] boston is [ __ ]
they were one of the two it wasn't
anything but whenever i went to new york
and i used to go to new york a lot i
loved new yorkers new yorkers are not
afraid of anybody they're not [ __ ]
snotty
new yorkers as somebody from mississippi
are very similar in the attitude
very similar i have been to new york
many many times um
over the years yeah and i [ __ ]
love new york city i love it
i would live there if i could afford it
i wouldn't live there i would i like to
visit it but i would
it's too [ __ ] crowded i i you know
what i'm not a people person
but for some reason in new york it
didn't bother me because
everyone is just kind of like man [ __ ]
you [ __ ] off which is what i'm like also
i gotta have motorcycles i gotta have
guns i gotta have
[ __ ] gotta go out in the wilderness and
i like to do [ __ ]
i like i like everyone like i like
everything being
open all the time i like people being
around all the time
but not like up in your face all the
time
i like that as far as yankees go i can
deal with the i like new yorkers as far
as yankees go
and um i like to like easties and
[ __ ]
boston from the easties and i like the
[ __ ] italians from new york
everything italians from boston i like
them
and irish and italians from from from
boston
[ __ ] i liked them a lot i did not
like the tourists or the college
students at all nobody likes tourists
anywhere ever no when you're a tourist
you kind of
yeah but boston is anal boston is very
anal
they worry about [ __ ] they're very
but i'll probably take new york over
that but
really today i'm just telling you guys
something the south
the south has risen again the south is
where it is to be right now
i'm from here florida texas
those are the places to be right now i
will tell you look i was born in florida
okay yeah um
it's cheap to live here i'll give you
that much for now
it's cheap to live here
but the jobs don't pay [ __ ]
jobs are gone jobs are now entered no
i'm saying
i'm a graphic designer i've been a
graphic designer for 20 25 years
um graphic design jobs here
pay the same as an entry-level job
maybe not even that much as would pay up
north
so i'm just saying that the standards
you know it's it's cheaper to live here
i will
give it that the rent is lower it's like
lower you know
the you know house price prices are
lower or whatever
like you get a nicer house for your
money
but the jobs really really do not pay
that much especially if you have like a
lot of
uh if you have a degree if you have work
experience like i have
it's kind of like sometimes i went to
interview for jobs
and like i said i've been a graphic
designer for what like 20 more than 20
years
and so like they were offering me pay
like
like i had just graduated from college
so
just be aware of that it is cheaper to
live here
but if you have to work down here the
jobs don't pay [ __ ]
kahn says that's another that's another
shirt boston is [ __ ]
yes boston is that so let's go but like
i said i've
i've only been to boston once or twice
but i've been to new york
a lot i i went to new york a lot like in
the 2000s
and i love that [ __ ] place i don't i
don't
i'm not really into like a lot of people
being around like i said but
it was kind of the same thing it was the
same reason why i loved london
like london is really crowded which i
normally don't like because i
don't like people in general but
if there's a lot of people around i like
that they just like
leave you to your own devices like
there's a lot of people around but they
don't want to engage with you
so i'm like so i'm fine with that tina
says she'd like to move to arizona but
it wasn't so hot
that's desert though that's a dry heat
[ __ ] you know i love the desert
you know where i really liked i was
really into
weirdly santa fe i really really liked
santa fe
i spent like a couple weeks there a few
years ago
and i really dug it it's very small
but there's like a big art community
there it's like really
it's cool you can like walk around it
there's a lot of like how long have we
been streaming
uh two hours and 37 okay yeah
because uh i don't know do you guys uh
want to continue the stream we will we
have to like dude i have this much dream
okay we'll finish the drink
i just got into this [ __ ] just you're
just getting into this all right
how i ended up going to santa fe was
that
my um my ex-husband is an oil painter
probably still is i don't know
but um he was going to
classes like with a with a guy that was
a
an oil painter that was like a you know
a mentor
so he was given some classes in santa fe
so he's like hey we can go to santa fe
we'll spend like you know
weeks there he's going to go to classes
you can go do your own [ __ ]
so i spent a couple weeks in santa fe
like pretty much by myself because he
was in classes all the time
i didn't think i'd be into it because
i'm not into deserts i'm not like i
don't like hot
weather i grew up in florida but
hot weather can like kiss my ass i don't
like it
so but i went out there and it was like
i don't know there's something about
santa fe that i really really liked
seattle said excuse me tila says seattle
reminded her of a [ __ ] cleaner
version of san francisco
t being california people you know like
i said my sister lived in seattle for a
while
me kind of in my real young phases going
between
long beach california and mississippi
you'd like florida if it what probably
wasn't for the humidity
florida really really reminds me of the
way southern california was when i was a
kid
reminds me of like uh
around the areas of vista and san diego
it doesn't
look like that but it's kind of like
that same makeup
we're right outside of uh orlando
orlando's [ __ ] beautiful
looks like something out of the office
it looks like something out of amusement
park
real nice new city um there's some about
new cities the way they're planned the
way they looked they just
they look a little bit like an amusement
park orlando is cool i will give it that
or the orlando tampa corridor is pretty
cool
it's called the i-4 corridor it is yeah
and yeah
and the i4 corridor really is mostly
populated with people that have run from
new york and california
you got a lot of people mostly new york
a lot of them they're not really from
here
but they're kind of integrating into the
area
um but it kind of the scene kind of
reminds me
of a young california uh it feels like
the future
like a place that has a future it
doesn't feel like a place that's kind of
existing in the past
that's the thing when i look at like
videos of [ __ ]
venice beach my mom was from venice i
look at venice beach and gold's gym
where arnold and everything came up
um i'll look at my neighborhood out in
carson the way it looks
now and man my [ __ ] my heart breaks
for that place
because those places used to be
beautiful but they're just
run down they look like something from
the past
and it's just because the economy you
know they don't have the money to
[ __ ] upgrade into that [ __ ] well
tila is asking here what about the east
coast area of florida
i'm actually from the east coast of
florida i'm from daytona
yeah that's where the scientologists are
and well now but that's
that's clear water that's the west coast
yeah west coast are you um
i grew up in i was born and grew up
first
20 something years of my life in daytona
now
daytona i don't know about melbourne
uh you know new smyrna all that kind of
[ __ ]
that's probably better um daytona i feel
like
when i was growing up it was very very
rednecky
um probably because of the big nascar
track there
yeah and you know the biggest nightclub
they had there was kind of like you had
like the meat market
[ __ ] which was called razzles yeah now
hold on too
and then you had the country bar yeah
and that was it
that was from another okay let me
straighten you out a little bit but i
haven't been there for a while they've
been like building it up but i don't
know how much better it is i've been
there for a couple
she's saying it's rednecky it is redneck
being
being black and everything that's not a
problem for you they're not they're not
they're not [ __ ] like hostile or
anything they're just
i don't know about that like i'm just
talking from my family perspective right
it's just and you're saying that's
that's not a dangerous place for black
my grandpa my dad i'm just you know not
scaring anyone but
i'm not saying anything that was another
era that's another error
just what you're saying think about it i
think all the black people we know live
in this area they [ __ ] love it here
tom's [ __ ] prospered
this [ __ ] club and everything no this
is a good place to move
taylor if you're if you're up in
california you got kids and [ __ ]
i know callie you'd love it here
you would i mean
if you can deal with the heat the heat
it's not the heat it's the humidity
well i know that's that's what i mean
it's like
orlando is interesting because
i don't know orlando is so weird it's
almost kind of like
it's not like a southern city like it is
but it's not
you know what i'm saying no because yeah
because what are you saying you kind of
have
that southerny rednecky florida thing
yeah
but you also have dude i grew up here no
it's not though
i grew up here right you didn't grow up
in mississippi it is not
that kind of redneck this is definitely
has
a [ __ ] very much of a spanish empire
[ __ ] flavor to it well that a little
bit
that's what i think there's that's why
it's weird because there's a lot of
and and you have to understand that
california kind of had there's a big
there's a cuban influence there's a
vietnamese right
kind of thing it's like there's a lot of
vietnamese it's more
it's only it's a lot like southern
california from the 70s and early 80s
it's a weird place that's what it is
it's weird right
but i will say for now
it is you do get a little bit more for
your money
rent wise um if you want to buy a place
you probably will get a little bit more
for your money here
versus california then you [ __ ] right
then you might in a bigger city yeah
that's all i'm saying
yeah you might get a little bit of
nothing california's ripping people off
i still got aunts and uncles over there
man i've seen their [ __ ] red
like in particular like i can see why
like like i said i
as much as i love new york city um
for what you're paying for rent in new
york city
you could get like a five bedroom yeah
just this huge
in florida this [ __ ] huge new house
is in a decent
this huge new house here is about
a wrench it's under 2000 1800 yes we
paid 1800 a month
this is a four bedroom three bathroom
house this house is 11 years old
yeah 11 years old yeah and and it's it's
in a gated kitchen
community it's [ __ ] got its own
swimming pools it's eight well 1800 a
month
covers also pretty much uh uh hoa
and it covers uh lawn care yeah they
come every week and
mow the lawn and trim the edges and all
that kind of [ __ ] and it looks like a
damn amusement park
looks like [ __ ] something out of
disney everything's all [ __ ] all the
hedges are trimmed and
the whole neighborhood looks like that
you have to it's a nice neighborhood
it's it's not one of the newer ones
they've actually like built a couple
like really fancy newer ones
like less than a mile yeah but and you
could never get something like this for
1800
1800 in california no it'd be three
times that
honestly um i think well honestly even
in this area like even if you want to
live in downtown lake if you want to
live near downtown orlando
eighteen hundred dollars is maybe going
to get you a two-bedroom apartment
maybe in one of those high-rises though
probably uh yeah like if you want to
live like right better than that we live
in about for that though
it's we live 18 miles from downtown
orlando it's 18 miles
yeah um you can drive there it's very
easy
um downtown sanford is what
seven eight miles something like that
there's
restaurants there's clubs and [ __ ] down
there too you know it's not as cool
obviously but the living downtown factor
isn't a factor in florida
there's nothing down there except clubs
you don't have to live there well the
thing about florida i will say too
if you live in florida you can't rely on
a public transit you have to have a car
everything is far apart um
florida in general because i feel like
people that grew up in like the
northeast
you know you can rely on public
transport to a large extent
and you don't really have to have a car
in florida you do
um if you don't have a car you are going
to be severely severely handicapped
because everything is very very very
very very far apart
see this is i'm telling you right now we
could we could have
a miami mansion if we would sell our
condo mood but yes you could
you could second and in it
you see some of them down porn [ __ ]
scenes and [ __ ] they're having
by the pool and all this weird [ __ ]
that's here florida that's florida well
how much were they
okay disney
and the porn scene has replaced [ __ ]
hollywood
it's all here all the porn all the
points here
yeah that's that's tampa and and
and miami that's where all that is um
florida is very orderly it has a good
local government
and that you're talking about the way
the way hollywood
uh in san francisco used to look in the
50s
that's kind of the way [ __ ] new
florida looks
it's just it's just run a lot better um
and you just get a lot more for your
money and it's just i i like it here
versus california well like
how much okay it's a lot better than
brazil here's what it okay there's a lot
of brazilians here
there are a lot of brazilians here they
move well there's a lot of everyone
yeah [ __ ] brazilian market which is
probably why i-4 is such
i could still get all the brazilian soft
drinks and all the [ __ ] brazilian
food that i grew up with i got
guadalajara on the [ __ ] back
refrigerator and everything
but it does have a very hispanic feel to
it
you know she grew up here so she doesn't
really know no
i do though but you know what's weird
too is that
you know there are so many british
expats
that live in central florida orlando
tampa [ __ ] like that
that if you go seriously you can go in
the publix a mile up the street
and there's like a little british
section there's all the british
yeah uh candy bars there's all that so
even if you're british you can [ __ ] it
and they have that in tampa as well
because there are so many like british
expats living here but what i was gonna
say was that
now we pay eighteen hundred dollars a
month which like i said includes lawn
care all that kind
and hoa fees and all that now
how much they must be getting bored
because we're losing all our listeners
how much did our uh landlords they
wanted to sell us this house
um how much what's that did they say
that this happened 375.
okay so this house they wanted 300 375
000. but in california this would be
like over so this house
that we live in is how many square feet
i don't know jenny uh it's big but like
i'm saying
i think it's for 1500 1600 something
like that
it's four bedroom three bath california
this would be more than a million
dollars
this house oh easily easily probably
1.3 it's a large it's it's large yeah
but here it's here under 400 000.
no no no no i think he wanted 425 for
this
i think he wanted 4.25 which like i said
try to sell it
for the area it this is not that bad
for the area it's not that bad for a
house this size
because this is a pretty big house i
mean it's not it's old
nikon said for 1800 a month in mexico
you can get a castle with your own
private beach and and [ __ ] con man
i ain't bullshitting you bro i'm into
that i'm into that
i'm into that move me down there i have
no i i love
i love south america i'm sure i could i
could you know
speaking portuguese i could fake spanish
i'll learn spanish i learned that quick
i took it for two or three years i'll
figure it
[Laughter]
i out love to move to mexico if i had a
[ __ ] good place and [ __ ] had
friends in the cartels
if i have friends give me that cartel
[ __ ] cover action
i could go down there and live in my
castle and
i'll have you and your wife over man and
your kids will take pictures like
[ __ ]
god we'll we'll have a [ __ ] dia de la
dillo
de los muertos [ __ ] [ __ ] photo
shoot dressed up like [ __ ] skeletons
and [ __ ]
with our top hats and our [ __ ] the
women will put them in veils
we'll have some leverage and carbines
it'll be like some [ __ ]
straight out it'll be like some [ __ ]
whole thing yeah it'll be well we
already talked about that [ __ ] we were
gonna [ __ ]
maybe like straight out of a fistful of
dollars
yeah because the [ __ ] i think the
future is in mexico
future's in mexico i don't think it's
going to be back in brazil though i
think brazil is permanently [ __ ]
honestly i am not at first
i think mexico is [ __ ] going to do
well it's gonna take time
i mean i don't mind living in the u.s
you know most of the time
yeah but um i'm not averse to like
living in other countries
i i honestly kind of i consider living
europe
i consider living in canada i can start
living in i consider living lots of
other places
so i don't have any particular tila said
that this house would be about 700
000 in the bay area probably yeah i
think about
yeah 425 i think he said xander says
what the [ __ ] is tom on about
i'm saying that xanada man if we have to
man we're going to run in mexico
there are people now this is people
their heads are [ __ ]
wigging they don't understand it you
look at mexico today
it's it's not the mexico that i knew
when i was a kid
it's [ __ ] nice you have people from
southern california white people from
southern california say [ __ ]
cali they move south to mexico
to tijuana the [ __ ] work hours are
better the [ __ ]
apartments are better and and it's got
good food i've seen it on tv
seeing that [ __ ] on tv yeah yeah to be
honest with you
it's like now that i have made the
transition
from working
an actual job which i hated and having
to like commute
to places to
uh scrabbling to earn a living on the
internet
which i'm doing but it's stressful but
you know
i'll work it out but that's one thing
that i feel like
people that [ __ ] on the internet dude
if you know what you're doing you can
make enough money to live on
not a lot i'm not making a lot i'm
making enough to live on
but that's cool though
which means that if i wanted to move
around
i could i'm going to wait until all this
[ __ ] covet [ __ ] is over
because i don't want to like give my
cooties to anybody
but if i man if we could move to another
country if we could what are you doing
i've got my charging cable see they
can't you thought it was some big
conspiracy to deny you of your
charging cables but there they are you
know how many did you get
five of them yeah they were only like
[ __ ] ten bucks got all the
relationships
you got a better deal than me yeah i got
a bulk deal
yeah another no 13 for three of them
another country that's supposed to be
swinging is [ __ ] poland
well supposed to be doing real well we
were talking about that the other day i
was like well
i would not be like i don't know it
would be hard
because you know dude i speak
english a tiny bit of spanish and a tiny
bit of french
that's it so it's like if i have to move
like look my stepmom is polish
so i'm not a verse but
man moving to eastern europe it would be
a big deal but i don't know i
i could i could deal with it whatever i
could deal with anything the food's
supposed to be great
oh
[Laughter]
refugee status says polish dudes are hot
as [ __ ]
this is that yeah zach's dating my step
well my stepmom is bullish
katrina yeah uh my dad
are they married i don't even know they
own a 7-eleven together
tiva said her peeps are expatriating to
portugal
yeah portugal [ __ ]
portugal that people have a funny accent
in portuguese it's not like they're
broken got potatoes in their mouths
but uh it's near spain well brazilian
portuguese and
portugal portuguese are different well
it's just kind of like
it's just kind of like anything it's
like spanish and like mexican spanish or
yeah
you know but um like i said i'm not
reversed to like
all right so you guys have any more
questions or should we go ahead and
check out we've been on for a couple
hours already
wait i'm not done with my drink yet okay
i'm having a good time you have a good
time
she's she's [ __ ] loaded she's gonna
how many cables there's five of them
no there was four cables yeah it was
five yeah there was five you're right
thank you i can count
they're good too they're like in uh some
kind of a braided
feels like braided kevlar zack says i'd
kill to move in norway
i've always been kind of like fascinated
with moving to like scandinavian
countries
yeah i feel like okay like correct me if
i'm wrong but
see tila says jenny's feeling no pain
i'm not she's going off about where
she's gonna move and everything now
well i know i'm like fantasizing about
it now i'm like well
they're telling it senators tell me to
go buy the old metal gear games
what are they better than [ __ ] part
five
those are fun the ones that you have
yeah
i love that like the [ __ ] character
in there is like based on
snake blisskin right yeah with the eye
patch and the mullet and everything
constant go look up nyat riviera
what's it called the riviera it's a
beautiful
so beautiful oh so he's talking about
place in mexico i think
i mean ideally if i was going to move
somewhere i want to move somewhere with
seasons
yeah yeah florida is just [ __ ] it's
so
kind depressing cool kind of cold and
then hot and humid
too that's one thing that always bummed
me out about [ __ ] i thought i was
supposed to give these people [ __ ]
some amsr and kind of
kind of relieve them well you can't but
i'm just saying like look okay
here's the thing let me tell you people
i was shut up
i was born in florida okay so i can
thank you all right so i can tell you if
you want to move to florida
okay one it's cheap to live here
okay but two if you need to work here
they're not gonna pay you that much the
pay is [ __ ] okay
so i'm telling you that right now but it
is cheaper to live here
three that's why it's cheaper to live
here yeah exactly
right you get more for your money like
if you have a bunch of money
like if you have like an inheritance or
something yeah move down here
and you can afford air conditioning in a
big house and [ __ ] if you have to work
down here
i wouldn't recommend it because like the
jobs
do not pay [ __ ] okay but i'm just
telling you that right
yeah now no they don't yeah i know but
here's the deal
i lived in boston and worked okay made a
[ __ ] ton of money and couldn't afford a
place like this
not in boston it all kind of works out
[ __ ] um it does but honestly i have
to say though it bums me out when
like me oh okay i went to college
speaker after designer i got a
degree and everything yeah tom switched
ads
a long time ago a long time ago you put
your crocodile dundee hat on
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm going back to [ __ ]
wigs
he's going back to the michael caine i'm
going back to my room he's he's going
back to the toxic
max masters toxic masculinity he might
strangle me we'll see
i'm going back to toxic masculinity stay
tuned
is he [ __ ] you who's he let me ask
you something
wait a minute who's he who are we
talking about he's that dude that's
[ __ ]
giving the yoga classes
i don't go to yoga but okay
but yeah so i'm saying that i'm just
saying that i
you know i um got a degree in graphic
design a long time ago like in 1997.
and it's it kind of bums me out like to
see
people in other cities like making
two or three times like what i would
make here in florida
so i'm just saying that if you still
have to work
for a living um
i'm not sure i would recommend florida
because florida's
the the wages are very low but
if you already have a [ __ ] ton of money
then probably florida is a good way to
go because
it's a very cheap you get a lot that's
already ha
that's already happening because that's
what i'm saying you have people that are
making money or were
you have to work for a living yeah no
don't but they had people who were
making a bunch of money in new york all
moving here and [ __ ]
this is where there's summer houses
which like i said i don't know swallows
little swoles parents have [ __ ]
summer homes i don't blame you for that
if you already have money yeah it's
cheap but it all kind of it all kind of
works out but i think it kind of works
out more for your advantage
if you can get a job here
or if you know how to make actually you
can you can make enough just on
on the internet if there's if you're a
family you got two people working
you can afford a pretty good place i
mean
where we're at now is not the best deal
there are better deals out there
especially out more towards the country
because if you're not commuting yeah
i mean if you're there's [ __ ] out there
for 750
a month if you're willing to live if you
don't have to
like commute to downtown with a lot
which a lot of people don't know it is
if you can live in the suburbs you can
actually
get a lot for your money in florida i
will say that
if you still have to work and commute i
would not recommend it
that's all i'm saying because commuting
on i-4
is a nightmare and also
um even if you have a
like a professional job you have a
degree and stuff you are not
going to get paid half
of what you would get somewhere else
but i'm just saying if you already made
your money
you're retired this is why like a lot of
retired people move down here if you're
retired and you have a lot of money
and you want to like make your [ __ ] go
farther then yeah move down here
and if you can take the humidity which
it's a lot okay i'm just telling you
it's a lot
to deal with see tila says you could
clean up in the bay area with graphic
design
i probably did but your rent mortgage
would be outrageous well that's what i'm
saying
it's a trade-off well and here's another
thing that she's not
i know those areas that we're talking
about i've lived in them
the quality of living here is a lot
better you don't have to worry about
bumper to bumper traffic
[ __ ] up neighborhoods uh you don't
have to worry about
the population density is not as
not as intense now there is in certain
areas
like if you go more towards downtown but
really those aren't really the best
deals the best deals are all out in the
suburbs or out in the country i mean you
go up
you can drive five minutes up towards oh
what's the name of this [ __ ] place
right
use this and there's [ __ ] out there
[ __ ] nice big ass houses for [ __ ]
seven
fifty eight hundred dollars a month they
just are
now they're something from the sixties
you know what i mean those looking
bricks they're not they don't look too
posh
but still they're pretty big [ __ ]
houses stuff that was made in the 60s to
the 80s there's stuff out there that's
looking very reasonable
and you just don't find things like that
out in california everything in
california i'm just saying that
you have to consider and you don't find
that in new england stuff like that
right but you have to consider um
what your lifestyle is what your job is
what your priorities are
what your priorities are it's like look
if you have
if you are independently wealthy or you
can work at home
um and you already have money like
you can you know work from your house
that and you can deal with humidity and
roaches
and various other things then okay
move to florida you can get a lot more
for your money and you don't have to
leave your house that much you don't
have to drive on i-4 you don't have to
deal with the humidity that's fine
the commute is nowhere near as bad here
as it would ever be i mean
if you have to go to a if you have to
like
go to a job and like [ __ ] i wouldn't
recommend it
but other than that
i don't like the weather here i gotta
say i'm not super into
i'm not into hot weather i i've lived
all over
i like this area some people who were
born in this area and lived in this area
their whole life they're kind of spoiled
i think they have it a lot better than
they than they they think they do um
they go visit other places and go visit
in other countries and uh you know i
mean for small periods of time and
it all just kind of works out the
standard of living here
i think is better uh that's just my take
on it but like i said well this happens
it depends it depends on your situation
you know
but it the economy here i think is
easier to deal with
i would i would not recommend it for
everybody the boston economy was
extremely [ __ ] when i was there was
extremely cutthroat
any weakness and you're gone only
successful people can live in boston
just the way it is if you don't have any
money you lose your job you're [ __ ]
out of there
they don't want you there the
corporations are like that too and just
if you're not at the top of your game
then you have to leave boston
this is how it is unless you go down the
easty
you know and then you'd be some you know
out in the [ __ ] irish hood but
there's
there's nothing really going on there i
thought it was kind of boring
i'd rather have [ __ ] more of a rural
area where you could do other things
but look look that's not what the point
of this show is do you guys have any
questions is that wait
is there any point in the show that was
the whole point of the show was she's
not
any point she's not feeling any pain
she's gone down this direction do you
guys have any questions
about any kind of cases or anything like
that
because we can i can you still have your
cocaine with
the cocaine what the michael kane way
guys yeah i got the michael king wig on
yeah
i thought you said the michael cocaine
the michael cocaine
no i said the michael cave because you
know [ __ ] i'll go down i'm
gonna go down and go down for the south
florida are you going the time
i'm gonna bring the cocaine in
the only thing i'm into from miami is
cuban sandwiches
yes i gotta say
tommy look like a little earth little
orphan annie these [ __ ] are [ __ ]
with me and that's something you do kind
of
yeah wait did you left booking
been a pleasure listening to you guys
tonight thank you that's a rickshaw so
thank you rick
this is fun we're going to do this every
week right yeah if you want
if if if the audience likes it we'll do
it every week we'll see
wait you got to show people you guys you
guys did you share my new game
no you do it get it good all right okay
you guys
now that most people have left i just
now that most people
now that most people have left show them
this i got this today
you guys know like you guys that are
long time listeners
i design board games this is my new one
this is
this is based on percy shelley mary
shelley
lord byron you know the haunted summer
where mary shelley
so this whole game basically
you have to play lord byron mary shelley
percy shelley
claire claremont for uh polydory john
polidori
you have to play one of those dudes and
you have to gather enough cards to like
put together your great masterwork
before somebody like drives you insane
there's some cool fake cards it's super
fun it's a board game
and this is one that i designed a while
back and i just now
put it for sale up for today just
i just got this like [ __ ] [ __ ] today
i'm very excited
so i'm just telling you are you guys are
these people in bed are you guys in bed
wait what time is it i don't know i
thought they were in bed listening to it
it's only eight o'clock it's only eight
o'clock
i mean i've gone to bed at eight o'clock
but i felt really bad about it
so i'm hearing that music that i'm going
like man
i just had to like say that because
i feel like i don't plug it enough
because david june coming in here
[ __ ] tom tell us about grits
are they made with or with what
are they made better with or with that i
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about like somebody okay [ __ ] are
always trying to [ __ ] troll me
into the before the [ __ ] okay before the
[ __ ] even started
for some reason i just remembered this
before the [ __ ] even started well we
still had the
like coming soon [ __ ] on
somebody asked if putting cheese and
grits was permissible
and i said name match is required man
yeah i said it's not even permissible
it's required you need to put cheese in
the grits
you need to put bacon in the grits you
need to put
but honestly anything that you want to
eat
you could put donuts in the grits i'm
not suggesting that
but i'm just saying you can put that in
the ground
yeah cheese is good ingredients i don't
know why wouldn't he
i don't know why we um
david jeans is still boozing here so are
we
this is my third but
they're so big that maybe
i don't know six what is it wednesday
maybe i am maybe i am a drunk i'm gonna
own it
look at this he left the hat and the wig
on the mouse on the mouse
love trolling tom in a southern food
seriously i haven't had grits in such a
long time
it's like i feel i'm on a diet so
i'm trying to lose 50 pounds
by end of march
and i've lost 10 pounds already so i'm
getting there
but you know
[Music]
but i don't know man i feel guilty about
eating anything
[ __ ] i cut back on it jenny
did you put the michael kane wig on oh
i don't think i've ever put that okay
give me that [ __ ] all right i'm trying
to go into the cutting
oh you'll find it i'm trying to put i'm
trying to get the cutting phase in where
i lose
a bunch of weight because i i gained a
bunch of bunch of [ __ ] muscle working
out now i got to lose weight so i can
get them cut
that look yeah you have a little lord
for nanny
that's it looks good on it i feel like i
should be in the musical chicago
yeah he has a comment yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly that's it
that's the first thing i thought of i
don't know
says he's never had grits dude man
where do you live okay well
okay how does all this grit [ __ ] go down
because i talked about grits a couple
times everybody wants to talk about
goods now
okay well grits are a thing like grits a
lot of people like to [ __ ] on grits but
the thing about grits is that they are
a palette that you may
paint upon to your liking
i mean they're no different than polenta
they're no different than
like bread even you could do the same
[ __ ]
with grants that you could do they're
because they have
little flavor of their own they don't
have a flavor no that's what i mean it's
it
you know and i don't mean that as like
[ __ ] to [ __ ] on them or anything but
they don't have a lot of flavor on their
own so
they're kind of like a canvas yeah you
can put your own [ __ ] off
so i mean i always liked them with just
like
butter salt pepper [ __ ] like that but
you can do whatever you want with them
you can put like [ __ ] boiled eggs
rick's from england he says they don't
have grit trees there
yeah i'm [ __ ] with you when i say the
grit trees grit and
grits do not come off trees well and
there is no season for grizz
yeah we're choking it's corn man it's
gone they're seeing that [ __ ] wig
look
and look great on you put that wig back
on jenny you're gonna put the whip
wait where's the cat okay
all right here it goes
i remind myself of somebody it looks
good
you look cute like that you got to get
you a big old perm jimmy
you go [ __ ] bigger trust me i've
tried
back in the 80s like i said
i really really wanted curly hair
because my hair is like [ __ ] straight
you guys you i don't know
and my great aunt was a hairdresser and
she used to come over to my grandma's
house and she would give me a perm all
the time and i would be super excited
because the perm would hold for a day
and then like the next
day the next day the perm would fall out
my hair um
wants to be straight and it just will
not brook
any insurrection against
the straightness it does not want to
curl
it just won't so it seems like marilyn
monroe and you should be working at a
diner
i don't know i don't like it
like i said the first thing i thought
was chicago
makes me want to kill it dude well i
think it's time to end this stream
do you think yeah i think so it looks
like uh looks like people are
in this dream so
what time is it now
eight or nine eight or nine over here
and we got [ __ ] we gotta do
so i was having such a good time
she didn't want to stop stopping no i
don't
[Laughter]
well [ __ ] man maybe i should start
preparing some wigs
just wear some wigs man give me that red
one i'll i'll wear that one now
that was my amy wig
now this one i liked because this one
oh [ __ ] i forgot somebody asked me
earlier
what my natural hair color was red
okay do you want me to show you a
picture here it is
here it is this is my natural hair color
look at look at that's a little baby bat
that was 1996
it's 1997. that's the way little goth
girls looked in the 90s
something like that that's what color my
hair was yeah
so you know i'm not lying yep i'm not
lying
that's what my hair color was just
so i totally forgot that i had the
picture of them
somebody asked me about that before but
yeah so this is kind of close
now calm wants to know some it's a good
idea for a show with the famous ufo
society from the united states well
i put like phoenix lights in there look
at what i'm doing
says wigs are awesome jenny you can be a
different girl these days a week
yeah yeah
yeah i don't have my [ __ ] like
yeah wait for my bangs okay see jenny
doesn't understand the long long big
hair it looks good on her
[Laughter]
ready for your next porn scene jay sure
put your big old [ __ ] boots on
[Laughter]
wait oh [ __ ]
[Music]
we have to watch the octopus one first
yeah we're going to watch the octopus my
friend
octopus tonight still early
right yeah yeah
tom forgets that something no listen to
her
did you look like a mermaid yeah
look like the mermaid little oh my god
you guys yeah
okay she gets drunk she starts hamming
up [ __ ] no
my aspirational my god
my aspirational like halloween costume
it's in my face this aspiration my
aspirational halloween costume
okay you guys watched dagon right
because we did a review on it
okay so the chick
that was in dagon that was
you know the head of the cult or
whatever she was like in the wheelchair
but also she had tentacles
a little spanish girl and then she had
oh yeah i want to do that
come with me you have to yes yes i want
to do that for a halloween costume
i need okay i need tentacles i need a
wheelchair
i need like the [ __ ] gold crown i
need oh it's
oh see even tina t man you've been
around for 33 you know your [ __ ]
tila for 33. you know your [ __ ] about
[ __ ] dagger wait what she's like
she's not how great did god was
this is a [ __ ] great movie see that's
seriously that
constantly has that [ __ ] on blu-ray
head order that [ __ ] on blu-ray
and what's-her-face from uh flash gordon
what's her name
yeah okay that and the chick from dagon
those are my
aspirational hospitals
flash gordon approaching oh and also my
aspirational halloween costume
previously
was i wanted to be um the
hindu goddess what was what's the one
with all the arms
uh yeah kali but then like heidi klum
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
because she did like a really awesome
costume of that
and she messed it up like i can't do it
now because
i'm too broke to like afford how awesome
that was
but seriously chick from dagon
and i i'm i'm into this
you're now into that [ __ ] she's into
that [ __ ] her hair was growing along and
she's getting too heavy i'm cutting it
off
i was like one night well seriously
one night i was drunk i don't even think
you watched me
i was drunk one night and your hair was
gone and
well okay the thing about dudes
well think about dudes what do i have to
do with you cutting your hair
you like long hair i like long hair yeah
but you don't
um have to deal with it on a daily basis
so you left that on you that's on you
yeah exactly
so my hair was so long that it was
one pissing me off two was always in my
face
three it was always clogging up the
shower drain
which was another thing so one night i
got a little bit like i wasn't drunk but
i was a little
bit inebriated i was like you know what
i'm cutting this [ __ ] off so i just went
in the bathroom and i just like cut it
off to my shoulders
because it was down to almost my butt
and it was super heavy mangoes [ __ ]
dispatch war rocket ajax to bring back
his body
remember when she said that we yeah well
do you remember
a year or two ago we were thinking about
we were gonna go i wish i was [ __ ]
russian i was should have either been
born italian
russian or black i should have been
[ __ ] one of those three
bring back one rocket injection russian
the russians are just not normal white
people they're they're [ __ ] not man
it's a whole other thing yeah they have
they have the whole one
they're not [ __ ] i respect that yeah
that's cool but you know what i mean
so a couple years ago not last year
before halloween we were thinking about
doing you were gonna be
what's his ass with the [ __ ] metal
mask from
flashboard what's his face oh that was
[ __ ] um
[ __ ] help me yeah i will you know there
was jimmy carla and [ __ ] um
colitis clyde is there colitis yeah so
he was gonna be clydus
and i was gonna be general kala yeah
and then we like we were watching the
movies and we're studying and i was just
kind of like and i did all this research
it's like man
okay so we have to make these costumes
and i'm gonna like
i figured out how to make them and it
was gonna be really expensive
and then i was kind of like well
i really want to do this but if we're
not going anywhere
like if we're going okay if we're going
to like a horror convention
yeah then i would spend the money we
were actually working conventions at the
time
we were so we were like thinking about
hey we should do this for the next
convention
we're going to be calla and clydus yeah
and [ __ ] i just kind of looked into
what it would take
to make a colitis outfit you're talking
about a grand
i probably would have spent it though if
you wanted it to look good
i mean about a grand and [ __ ]
the thing is those that i have to make a
lot of that [ __ ] by hand there were a
lot of these little [ __ ] plastic
[ __ ]
plastic [ __ ] tubes i don't forget
what they're called they're like little
lucite tubes
yeah yeah to make general collis [ __ ]
wood which yeah she had like a whole
like thing there and like a whole
headpiece these are very expensive
costumes and you have to make them by
hand
they were originally made by hand but i
would love to go as colitis
and [ __ ] have you as general i'm
still into that i
i still want to do that but the good
news about clydus is that the general
clydus costume he
his arm was a solid piece of [ __ ]
gold
i think i would have modified it so it
had a hinge on it like a robotic arm
well you want to make it functional make
it more functional because i don't want
to sit there with a straight arm off
like
all day you know what i mean but that
would have been pretty cool for some of
some of the conventions
but i did look into because i really
really wanted to make
like the general akala at least her
headpiece
but when i was looking at looking at
that it was like man like they had all
these like [ __ ] lucite pieces
and it's like really cheap to make back
then but like nowadays
it'd probably be really expensive to
make i don't know
i still want to do it but i still want
to do the [ __ ]
chick from dagon too we got zach in
there talking about all the different
kind of european guys he's been dating
zach and russians and finnish people we
got
tila saying she's gonna make some vodka
and pomegranate yeah vodka pomegranate
worked pretty good
that's pretty good vodka goes with
everything that's why it's the best of
booze
yeah and then [ __ ] badger says yeah
give me some of that tv
this is my i mean vodka is my go-to
vodka doesn't have a flavor of its own
other than drunk the flavor is drunk
yeah it's drunk flavor drunk flavor
so you can mix it with anything yeah
i mean whatever i have in the fridge do
i have apple juice in the fridge do i
have [ __ ]
bailey's in the fridge everybody hit
that like button please hit that like
button
i know we're ridiculous i know
[Laughter]
we're going to put look i have a [ __ ]
red curly wig on yeah do you want to
make another drink
sure so you're enjoying the stream and
now all of a sudden these people come on
i'll make you a half okay
i'm getting into like the wig action
it's red this is seriously this is
this is like my natural hair color so
i'm always kind of like having a
flashback
to the old days
but yeah so although like i said i never
had cool
curly hair much as i wanted it
never worked out i think the most
the longest time that it lasted
was maybe 48 hours
i kept asking because like i said i grew
up in the 80s and
perms were very were very much the thing
so my great-aunt betty thank you
my great-aunt betty was a was a
hairdresser
and she would come over to my grandma's
house
where we all hung out at some of us
lived at it was kind of like the weigh
station
he's town you get a bunch of wigs
daytona i have a couple
yeah but this is my favorite t-e-t
she's gonna she's gonna [ __ ] tell a
white girl to get all your goddamn wigs
you're gonna get t you're gonna get her
into that fake hair [ __ ]
like you all do you're gonna [ __ ]
corrupt her next thing you know every
time i turn around it's a different kind
of woman
why it's going to be a different why
would you have a problem with that
is she tila is [ __ ] putting the
blackness on you can't understand it
well because i feel like dudes
no i i understand tila you're right man
she does need some bunch of different
hair
dudes a bunch of different hairs i got
hairs
all different kind of hairs dudes in
general they have a thing where
she said tom will have a blast that's
what i'm saying
dudes in general they're they have this
weird thing where it's like i don't
really
like i don't like to hang out with the
same person
like i love you but i don't like to hang
out with the same person
everybody's gonna have a wig party she's
trying to so so they're always kind of
like well
i wanted to still be you but like not
look like you
so they have that thing no you have to
understand something this is straight
see tila knows the deal
they have that thing tila understands
the way men work
men are animals okay yeah no [ __ ]
working in the horse industry i will
tell you
if you have a same broodmare in the same
[ __ ] stud you're trying to [ __ ]
breed horses
sometimes putting another mare next to
that broodmare will [ __ ] get that
stud interested in that that mayor again
because he's already had sex with her
you know what i mean
that's what i mean so you got to get him
[ __ ] riled up to have sex with her
again sometimes putting another female
next to it
now i've heard that [ __ ] changing the
color of that mare well to get him to do
that
because dudes are simple and like it's
just
it doesn't have anything to do with that
it's pretty it's not because it's
evolutionary pre-programming
yeah it's simple it's it's it's for
for males of all species yeah is that
it's a simple
reaction about you this is a new one
impregnate this one right your program
for that right yellow dumb
so you have to like it's not the
dumbness see look at how these women are
it's not a dumbness
it's just that that was the that was the
reproductive strategy
that [ __ ] survived and was
genetically enforced over the millennia
not only within human males but all
males
are like that right yellow dumb it's not
that i mean these [ __ ]
it's not that it's not don't be such a
snowflake
you're trying to moralize something that
is not moral
okay it's just a function it's a
function of men the way they work
men are not so much attracted to beauty
they're not so much attracted to [ __ ]
this or that
what men are attracted to really isn't
is novel novel t-shirts novelty just the
fact that
we know that that's all it is you know
men like novelty and
males of all species like novelty it's
so this is the [ __ ] upside and the
downside of it girls
don't in a way don't take the [ __ ]
personally
which that's kind of i would think that
would be insulting to a woman to a woman
that it's not really personal to us but
in a certain way it is
if he stays with you for a long amount
of time then it is personal
because it's not just the sex it's who
you are
if he hits and [ __ ] moves on then it
was a person
that's the difference well yeah i think
that's that's the difference
all right i mean me and you
were friends and hanging out when we
were with other people
you were married i was married and then
i was [ __ ] a couple other dudes yeah
and i was dating disney princesses and
[ __ ] we were double dating
oh yeah remember that i was so
we were trying to like one-up each other
yeah because well we were friends
we were sinisters i think i [ __ ] we
were seeing two or three other dudes
yeah yeah and i was dating [ __ ]
at least two maybe more but we were
buddies we were buddies
before all the [ __ ] between me and you
went down anyway
we were in a way we kind of became
business partners before we were even
[ __ ] in a relationship
so that actually women might be what the
[ __ ] is that all about
but two dudes that are listening to this
they're like oh
okay yeah yeah it's a totally different
dynamic
for us that's a little more serious well
it's kind of weird how me and you
happened it was a different [ __ ]
topic because
when me and you met in case
because like i said she was married this
is a new topic
i was married to another dude yeah
when i met you he was a barbarian well
he was a barbarian from somewhere up in
the [ __ ] uk
he's well i couldn't even understand
that dude i was talking to him he's like
he's fine he's a lovely man so in case
he's watching
he's a lot like i don't have anything
against it
it's just that okay so i met that dude
man i got married when i was 22
23 very young
now we were married for 14 15 years
and then at some point i met you and i
was kind of like man i'm like kind of
getting sick of this whole marriage
me and my now ex-husband
i was kind of like look i kind of like
i i got to do my own thing like just
chill out with the [ __ ]
so he was like fine with it he was like
all right well we're gonna get divorced
but
just do what you want okay so i just did
what i wanted
for a while so
you know [ __ ] happened at the time
they are well honestly and i don't mean
this is
like i know a lot of dudes are watching
this but like seriously
from a girl's point of view from a
girl's point of view
um dudes are kind of like um
your children they're like children
they're like your children
that's some [ __ ] ain't that some [ __ ]
i don't think i'm being controversial
here i'm just saying
that's kind of how you approach it it's
kind of like
you approach them like children because
that's kind of like what they
act like and that's kind of like what
they i mean i don't know
dj maniac says there's no more [ __ ]
scene in new york because of the
pandemic everybody's left man look man
let me tell you something
maniac i'll [ __ ] feel for you bro
whenever i passed through new york it
was a i had a good time i had a good
time down the [ __ ] village and [ __ ]
man i cut them away and and uh i went to
the drop dead
mayor man what's his name cuomo cuomo
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up and now he's like oh
you know what
these lockdowns we're not gonna have
anything when we open back up he's now
trying to reverse that [ __ ]
yeah dude that's what they [ __ ] told
you
our governor you got people that don't
like him but i like descendants because
he
he was he was moderate he's like yeah
you do the math do the social distance
don't worry so much about the lockdowns
that's on you guys
and it was so much better here it did
not [ __ ] destroy
all the restaurant all the restaurants
in new york are [ __ ] gone
at least the restaurants we liked
they're still open they're still exist
well so it's because they were able to i
mean the restaurants that are around
they worked it out they worked it out
they worked it out i mean the indian
restaurant that we were into that's all
i care about they don't do the buffet
anymore obviously because that's super
germy
but they still do take out and you can
still
eat in there as long as you're i argue
i argue as having a [ __ ] background
and food service
that that [ __ ] buffet is jeremy
they're not that german they're always
german you have to know because that
buffet
had the [ __ ] plate to have the
[ __ ] glass
and it's not it's not is that just for
sure though no
and it's not as risky as you think
nowhere near what you think
they blew that [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
proportion well in normal circumstances
i would agree
no it's not a big deal that [ __ ] no
i don't make me mad it look
flue is flu that's what it is
oh yeah i ain't gonna talk about it i
don't want to talk about it because i
don't want to get [ __ ] banned
through this [ __ ] here then look
there's always blessings i'm mad i'm mad
there's always blessings in disguise and
the blessing that we're having now is a
diversification i like diversification
and a non-centralization of diversifying
the internet
there should not just like back in the
days of the railroad
when the railroad was a bunch of
monopolies they [ __ ] dominated the
united states people thought the world
was going to end because of the [ __ ]
railroads
the railroads had their own court
systems that would pass death sentences
on [ __ ]
employees there are places on the
railroad where there's [ __ ] hundreds
of [ __ ] irish
dead bodies and chinese dead bodies and
mass burials
that nobody really knows what the [ __ ]
happened these big corporations are a
[ __ ] risk
and big tech is a [ __ ] risk to
everybody they need to [ __ ]
this top-down centralized system that
these [ __ ] want
for monopolistic purposes and power
everything has to diversify
diversifying everything is the key to
making everyone happy and to stop all
this [ __ ] fighting
uh look i fought for the [ __ ] united
states
and i [ __ ] i hate what i'm seeing in
the country
and even just like what they said in the
comments
social media has been very destructive
because it is not diversified
that's the problem oh everybody needs to
[ __ ] just try to get through the time
everybody needs to get through this hard
time and understand
that a [ __ ] loves you don't
believe what those [ __ ] say
this is a [ __ ] good country it is not
a bad country
[ __ ] trying to make the [ __ ] worse
will come back and bite you in the
[ __ ] ass
this [ __ ] will pass it's divided right
now
but in a way it's artificially divided
it's not as divided as you think it is
they're making it divided because it
benefits them
the biggest divisions in this [ __ ]
country i've seen the data
don't have anything to do between white
and black or this the biggest divisions
are between who has a college degree and
who doesn't that's where the biggest
degree is
oh my goodness i have a college yeah
that's the biggest
all you gotta do is look at the money
look at the money that's the biggest
division
i have a college degree about it you got
a dollar yeah that's really where the
division is
it's not only all this other [ __ ] is
about making other people [ __ ] money
and giving them power
don't believe the [ __ ] hype all right
but america's the america
america's coming back it's gonna come
back it's gonna take time
i told you man chill out i'm [ __ ]
pissed about this [ __ ] but hold on
it's getting late it's getting late in
the show dude
getting late in the show unlocked
she said taylor said put on a wig
girlfriend and what you're talking about
i love it yeah
that's so pretty right now
those are pretty my fat arms but yeah so
uh what was i gonna say oh dude
please calm down i'm not calm seriously
i mean i know this [ __ ] is i'm not
even gonna
i'm not gonna get started on the
politics because it'll hurt your
feelings
it's gonna hurt your feelings but i'm
not gonna get started on that
i'm not dividing any woman okay i'm just
saying
even though i feel like maybe we should
do some dividing
yes you know all right well okay look we
gotta go
i'm just saying it's like we got people
we look
okay but what were you talking about
it's about time to [ __ ] end the
stream
is it yeah i think so we've been on for
a long time
and it looks like a lot of people are
gone
[Music]
do you want to put your i guess michael
caine
[Music]
i have my pretty wig on yeah all right
everybody
thanks for joining us tonight and uh
we're gonna do another
uh stream like this probably next week
next wednesday
yeah we're gonna you know what i think
that she's [ __ ] drunk
no okay shut up okay we're gonna start
doing this every wednesday yeah
that's what i was gonna say right is
that
because before we were doing like
wednesday we were doing like a matinee
but i kind of feel like y'all give [ __ ]
about the movie reviews
okay we'll come up with something um so
i feel like wednesday evenings it's
midweek
yeah so maybe we should do another this
kind of [ __ ]
yeah and we will kill our livers
for you guys well we'll try to perfect
this more
make sure that we have the right music
in the background we have a little bit
more of a [ __ ] punchy [ __ ]
delivery
maybe we'll have a little bit more of an
outline next time
so we can you know what i mean oh don't
move don't stress me out
seriously well no like i feel like
i like the whole like not
jacqueline says can't wait for [ __ ]
next week yeah
this is jenny's hammered she's [ __ ]
hammered i am that's one of the reasons
why i'm trying to shut this show down
because she's [ __ ] hammered
it's good what do you think is gonna
happen that's what's gonna happen just
i'm saying
we've been up we've been on for several
hours we've been on for seven
hours we've been on for several hours
he's afraid
no it's fine i'm yeah i'm drunk but like
look this is my forest she said levers
can regenerate
this is my fourth devil oh we gotta
watch tonight anyway
yeah we did you guys [ __ ] you gotta
see my friend the [ __ ] doctor
well i know but like we don't have
anything that we have to watch like for
yeah for a review did you what did you
guys think of the music let's get some
suggestions this is the first show i'd
like to know
i just like downloaded some random [ __ ]
from
uh free music archive and it was like
vaporwave and i just like
downloaded all this [ __ ] yeah and some
people were kind of like i liked some of
it and not so much
other stuff but i was kind of like well
i don't really have time to
sift through all this [ __ ] so i'm
just kind of like
any feedback yet on it okay
but you know why isn't it wearing this
way they said the news was okay
we'll uh i think i can come up with
something a little bit different though
well i'll send me the [ __ ] yeah i'll
send you help me i'm gonna send you like
a
send you like some mixed music that are
from well help me various from various
friends and
that i am allowed to use that is not
going to like
get me okay here's the thing here's the
thing here
you're not going to get me like a
[ __ ] t here here's the thing
if we put 80s music on there there's
going to be copyright files that's what
i'm saying
it's gotta be something that is just
background music or something that's
like for [ __ ]
free music that's a problem
okay so we can't put any copyrighted
music on there
i was thinking about putting some google
music on there
well that's why like i said that's why i
kind of was just like hey
what's some like free music that i can
use and i was just kind
of like but we'll see you guys next week
we'll kind of try
it thanks for joining us well saturday
we'll be back
we're back saturday we're going to be
talking about heaven's gate yep
on saturday yeah and we will see you
there yeah
bye-bye why am i wearing this wig i
don't know
all right we'll see you guys saturday
we're talking about the heavens gate
cult
[Music]
and we'll see you then thanks for
dropping by